une production du studio sf bio venus au
sans filtre le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités date site
super h quand tu aimes pas avec moi
aujourd'hui de me plante le sans filtre
cette semaine et présenté par le sans
filtre vip sans filtre viiip c'est notre
deuxième petit bébé c'est la deuxième
podcast c'est exclusif aux membres
pétulante c'est un podcast risque on
s'entretient avec des gens notre
entourage que des gens moins connus du
grand public que dans le sens filtre
mais des gens tout aussi intéressant on
fait exactement ce qu'on fait dans le
podcast que vous écoutez présentement
donc on parle ce qu on veut que nos
invités date site
on a reçu mon agent on earth eu ma soeur
on ne reçut cousin de dôme puis le cette
semaine lorsque quelqu'un qui est
spécial pour moi là dessus on a reçu par
dont xavier desharnais qui étonne mes
bons amis avec qui j'ai nagé pendant au
dessus de 20 ans qui lui s'est
spécialisé dans la lulu de l' ultra
longue distance de notation dont il
gagné deux fois la traversée du lac
saint-jean qui 32 km de natation c'est
une épreuve
en fait c'est quelque chose qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de monde qui te peuvent
dire avoir fait pilule a gagné deux fois
puis quelque chose qui vraiment
particulier avec xavier c'est qu'ils le
ferment étant vegan fait que ça me
rejoint encore plus les thébains avant
moi puis c'est une des raisons pourquoi
je suis passé aux organismes en fit un
appui venu avec son coach de l'année
passée bertrand venturi et un français
qui a lui aussi je crois gagner à
traverser ou le fait du moins plusieurs
fois une convention est trop
intéressante si vous vouliez avoir accès
dirigez-vous vers notre page piquionne
qui va être dans la description du
podcast puis en plus d'avoir accès à ce
contenu exclusif la surpiqûre vous avez
accès à tous les podcasts en avance et
c'est la meilleure façon d'encourager si
vous aimez qu'est ce qu'on fait
dirigez-vous vers pétrone puis encouragé
nous sur cette plateforme la sueur sur
cette semaine on a reçu hop dance et qui
est robert nelson du groupe alaclair
ensemble
c'est un personnage
complètement fait ce nom on a parlé
longuement de sa relation avec le
cannabis aux jeunes qui est un fervent
défenseur de la démocratisation du
cannabis en fait de l'usagé cannabis à
des fins positives lui-même c'est un
consommateur régulier on en a parlé
longuement crise est il très éduqué sur
le sujet ce qui permet de mieux
comprendre un petit peu les enjeux de
choses là ensuite évidemment de parler
d'être dans la classe ensemble nous
parler de son rôle dans ce groupe on a
parlé de la direction artistique du
groupe en fait et on a aussi parlé d'un
pro pleine affaire d'engagement social
aussi c'est vraiment une personne
atypique mais souvent ça fait les
meilleurs conversation comme vous allez
voir le on aurait continuer encore
pendant deux heures avec eric dane
comme c'est le cas avec beaucoup de nos
invités en fait on est assez choyé de
recevoir des gens aussi intéressant puis
pour donner puis montre que c'est un
espèce de d'apprentissage en continu si
vous aimez ce qu'on fait comme j'ai dit
alors via notre page spéciale mais sinon
vraiment un like un commentaire un
abonnement notre chaîne
un rythme de 5 étoiles sur les
applications audio
ça fait vraiment son bout de chemin
gestion le répète à chaque fois mais
c'est tellement important si on veut
continuer à faire ça si on veut
continuer à grossir comme on le fait
déjà
on approche l'un à tout ça est
extrêmement excitant puis bon écoute et
mon podcast
[Musique]
2 1
je pensais partie fake way continue on
continue ce qu'on dizaine en reparler de
reparler cannabis là bas les experts bah
écoutes je me suis je consomme intéressé
à ça plus sérieusement une couple
d'années quand j'ai réalisé que type
pour de façon réaliste à moi je faisais
des gros changements dans ma vie
j'allais souvent consommer encore
pendant le bout's et puis que il y avait
des façons plus ou moins intelligent de
le faire puis que j'étais rendu un
moment où ça serait comme wild takkal
c'est un peu ce que je dis à tout le
monde ses causes dans vie en général ces
must comme s'ils étaient capables de
tripes et invisible a déjà puisqu'elle
est a pas besoin de rien consommer pour
quoi que ce soit vraiment aimé comme si
jamais été dans une situation de temps
consomment déjà petit de façon réaliste
je pense que des bonnes chances que tu
risque de continuer à faire mais je
pense que c'était vraiment juste gagnant
comme thème informé la du petit joseph
on n'est plus à une époque en ce moment
t'as jamais eu autant de facilité à
t'informer sur la chose
curé parce que c'est là exactement de
ces faits que c'est comme ces sites a
envie d'avoir tout petit peu non
seulement aller directement voir des
gens qui sont spécialisés dans fournir
des conseils médicaux mais superbe comme
farhangi met c'est de l'auto
apprentissage aussi dit oui un peu de
familles très longtemps c'est déjà un
peu ça me fait ça mais le délire là
dessus mettre le doigt pour deux ans ça
change là ça change de quad c'est
surtout
jean sébastien fallu d'ailleurs il fait
beau il parle beaucoup de
il parle de la diminution des méfaits la
diminution des effets secondaires
néfastes
c'est comme toutes les drogues annoncé
puis comme quand tu es capable de un peu
les réduire et contrôler c'est ça
exactement au moins ya sept ans à
charles bon dosage la bonne sorte qu'il
imagine que tu as découvert ce qu'était
le centre ça marche mieux qu'ils étaient
déjà en marche mieux
vraiment je te vends savoir qu'ils
géologie le bon buzz mais j'ai pas
l'effet négatif qui me qui me dérangeait
voyez exactement 40 ans à peu c'est une
équipe aussi découvrir qu est ce que tu
aimes pas du genre comme farc et ben si
tu vois ça j'ai pas besoin de ce pour
ses enfants comme mettons c'est moi
j'aime pas la spéciale d'actifs dans le
noir à la baisse dit fitch a de la
ressource et la sphère anthony siva
comme endormissement c'était était verte
le célébrer du classique la psicom comme
n'importe quelle fut ma cause des fois
ça m'arrive de tomber dans les
stéréotypes mais comme c'est clairement
pas ce que je recherche à la base on
peut l'éviter ou du moins on peut
diminuer fortement les risques fait que
jusqu'au vu qu'on joue avec la chimie
interne ne veut pas dire qu'on est en
train d' altérer des états de conscience
des choses comme ce t il
tu peux avoir une certaine prévisibilité
même s'il ya plein de facteurs aussi
c'est un degré de fatigue et se manger
ci était tout en aidant c'est pas juste
et émotion en général etc
mais clairement je pense comme c'est
vrai par rapport à l'alcool c'est vrai
par rapport au café qui serait pas aussi
jeudi
maintenant on le titille tu peux boire
des des alcools qui sont plus de qualité
effectué au moins un lendemain de veille
2 mars vers ce jeu comme ça ça reste a
bu de l'alcool sur la gueule ça va
l'être si je balance
mais déjà pris cette zone je pense tout
le temps tu parles de sédation puis moi
c'est exactement ce moment où est ce que
je te dis plus jamais je vois consommé
de cannabis et quand quand je prenais
par exemple ne faisant brownies avec des
amis puis là on avait juste aucune foi
qui me déplaisent ne retrouvait
finalement pas d'une souris comme je
t'ai craquer part je voulais broad von
braun en soirée puis tu es maintenant
dix ventes sur power passes n'étaient
pas gardés en la personne de gad
d'enchaîner des mots tu regardes le vide
il faut qu'on porte attention s'ils
n'ont pas bien d'oser nationale comble
et puis tout parlait presque penser que
j'étais conscient du fait que je me
disais le monde trouve ça complètement
métier mettant ce que tu décris le sait
ce que c'est particulier parce que c'est
ça une overdose de cannabis
c'est ça la réalité gentil sur une
overdose de cannabis c'est à dire que
comme c'est un des derniers systèmes qui
a été découvert par là la science
moderne mais tous les êtres humains
comme kutcher ou non genton un système
endocannabinoïde c'est un truc genre les
biologistes explique cela par le fait
que à une époque vraiment lointaine la
vie n'est pas très avancé puis une gens
de laval guy je sais pas trop de lits
ses commandes
bref c'est un truc toutes les espèces
vivantes pansement sur temps aux gens de
système endocannabinoïde puisque ça veut
dire c'est que comme partout dans ton
corps des récepteurs
puis ce système leur influence est ton
humeur voire influencer ton énergie va
influencer son appétit vont influencer
plein de choses des choses qu'on dit que
le cannabis est cadre ou un impact là
dessus puis par un espèce de mystère de
biologie un peu intéressants la molécule
ducati les cannabinoïdes le cannabis
c'est quelque chose qui fit exactement
dans ces récepteurs la fnam et ont le
même principe que la vitamine mettons de
ces gens peut influencer comme tonton
qu'en prenant une vitamine c est france
est ton système endocannabinoïde la
vitamine extérieur c'est le cannabis
était faible c'est comme si ce principe
le tipi mettant comme les gens super
bien en général avec le thc puis le cebr
insys icom les deux cannabinoïdes
principaux les deux principaux puis
comment ça fonctionne c'est que le thc
vient comme ouvrir des récepteurs de
cannes indiqué les cannavino récepteur
la 6e du cbd l'a par la suite des
départs entre et des fois y'a pas de cbd
comme des soeurs de cannabis pilotage
issu le triage qui rentre et est même l
état de georges suivait depuis jeudi +1
crise et mocky georges boit pas
mais ceci comme quand tu étais récepteur
ont été jusqu'au bout puisqu'ils font
l'instant le sait qu'il s'est fait
complètement fi gens sont comme ok on
est comme on aurait pu rien savoir se
fixer comme c'est le jeu vulgarisateurs
scientifiques pourraient probablement
corriger certains détails mais c'est la
vulgarisation mais grosso modo 6 au tiff
exquis qu'andy et moi j'aime pas
l'alcool parti comme c'est utile
vomissements toilettes par le mal de
tête subtile comme ben oui fraîcheur
métier c'est possible de qom puis bref t
on dirait qu'on le 6 par rapport à
l'alcool
c'est comme une certaine culture déjà
même si t'es pas un connaisseur d'alcool
tchèque du fort ça se prend soin d'eux
du smoothie otages ont risqué en europe
où jean tu prends une petite quantité
mais tu sais j'en tiens personne se fait
1-1 avec l'être quand je vois quelqu'un
qui fume pas souvent plus gentil qui
comme m j'ai juste pris un poste mais
jusqu'au bruit mais d'après une poche de
type comme ce new bag le tbhc comme je
viens c'est comme quelqu'un qui boit pas
beaucoup qui viennent s'aligner cette
chute de suite qui dirait l'alcool ça me
plaît je précise va du petit bar à côté
no joe qu'amazon le 6 le monde du monde
craint beaucoup bien donner un coup
d'essai pour le fun le 6 mai la
meilleure option que moi je conseille
c'est trop une seule poche une seule
littéralement puis prendra une toute
petite j'ai fait comme littéralement
parti ata voit ce que ça te fais tu vis
au dessus des autres supports thème tout
tenté pour sa part de 2 le genre jusqu'à
maintenant ça fait part en mettant un
béké martiniquais ça et on présentera
pas combien de temps tu comment faire
sentir de quoi où tu sais si tu as
besoin d'en apprendre plus ou moins si
je dirais même si tu pour être prêt
littéralement même comme te dire qu'ils
se préparent comment je me sens j'en
prendrais pas plus qu'il n'est que tu
pourrais m'étendre dire s'appuie comme
genre je vais pouvoir par la suite
mythiques comme guéri jay style piguet
comme si c'est vraiment ce que je
suggère au monde puis comme ceux qui ont
envie d'essayer type ce que c'est
vraiment comme ça c'est juste ici c'est
d'en prendre aussi d'aider à petit
teneur en thc il ya des choses comme ça
puis pas fumer du cannabis qui sont
sédatifs 6 passes recherche c'est
vraiment c'est important parce que comme
they know jack
quant aux expérimentés un break seul
woods qui se rapproche plus d'un pur
somnifères puis en une que c'est
quasiment comme du café comme tu chantes
ont admis qu axa la piasse morales comme
fils qui m'a impossible le fait que
c'est assez fascinant pour moi tous mes
titres jusqu'à présent ma raison que la
manière de le faire du chemin de fer du
chemin mais tu t'es pas obligée depuis
maintenant pour influencer son système
endocannabinoïde c'est comme le chemin
l'influencent donc c'est comme commenté
ted les bonnes habitudes de vie tu sais
un impact sur sur toute ta santé c'est
sûr qu'au milieu du monde à berck comme
la la la ils sont en parfaite santé
puis leur système en du cab l'idée est
en équilibre mais n'ont jamais consommé
de leur vie s'est fixé comme c'est plus
que ya certaines personnes en deux que
leurs systèmes ados kabyle et des
balances et puis que ça pourrait
potentiellement com est une genre de
vitamine c comme pauvres contre les
commencer et puis c'est morsay même
principe que plein de types de
médicaments ou de suppléments le puits
toute l'europe à leurs effets négatifs
possibles de ce mets tout est un
consommateur régulier
imagine si quoi les bénéfices que partir
de cette consommation le bain c'est
assez complexe c'est parce que comme moi
sherco je suis pas un cas comme de jeu
par avalanche a dû lui que j'avais comme
un problème médical puis que j'ai
réalisé que c'était comme un peu comme
le remède dirais que j'adore ça a
commencé comme un comportement
clairement récréatif mais tellement
jeune aussi c'est à dire que chabal en
catégorie d déclare nick c'est à dire
qui comme c'est moi je suis plus dans
une housse film pour me sentir jusqu'au
nord c'est exact c'est comme le piège me
posez moi même avions devrait petit à
petit qu'ils fument beaucoup depuis très
longtemps c'est un peu ça c'est que la
réalité j'ai plus de place dans ma vie
j'étais à gages
moi je suis comme un peu à propos de
sortir du placard en guinée a pas de ces
choses là dessus parce que autre côté je
conseille à personne d'avoir cette
relation là avec quoi que ce soit mais
man et ça existe ça existe ça existe des
millions de personnes à travers le monde
sait qu'en dit c'est pas juste ça va pas
juste complètement runitel vie non plus
petits c'est fait qu'il ya comme une
espèce de zone grise puis dans le code
quelqu'un qui peut être pas rendus au
stade où se dit jean québec comme je
vois virer ce petit but qui n'avait pas
vraiment comme un peu retard 0 milles 7
je pense qu'une bonne stratégie en
attendant de peut-être un jour devant la
cedh est justement c'est comme avoir une
approche du belge pour moi essayer de
diminuer ce que moi j'aime pas
puisqu'elle peut-être mai prochain pas
de certains de mes 2
la dame c'est une joie de relation amour
haine avec cette substance là où c'est
juste amour entre eux non il ya l'amour
en clamant parce que j'ai pu société
machines des personnes qui est qui qui
peut dire que les gens qui disent qu'il
ya pas de désintox cannabis c'est comme
se parle c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
vraiment vraiment du gros n'importe quel
dépendance physique aussi absolument et
puis c'est qu'avec toutes les formes de
dépendances il ya deux types de phase de
la phase des symptômes comme si on veut
immédiat c'est quand même et on agit pas
laisser paraître
le premier soir de prendre mais je suis
beaucoup plus exact ce genre de son de
l'opic souvent après une semaine deux
semaines trois ce n'était plus là dedans
puis le tutu vit ce que dans la culture
de la d'un texte on appelle le pink
cloud juste au dessus du toucher à comme
le bonheur ou comme le fait d'un riche
comme le tout à coup vous sembliez le
chipeau la tutelle complète si je
redécouvre un peu comme ça c'est
vraiment nice mais le vrai défi je pense
de n'importe quelle vraie dépendance
c'est ce qu'on appelle le poste qt ou
agent en fait mais c'est comme la phase
qui vient plusieurs mois après quand on
système comprendra le fond qu'un leurs
prières caisse comme qu'il faut faire
une restructuration comme l'ont terres
fertiles et trucs classiques qui sont
associés à cette phase là puis c'est
vrai que ce soit une dépendance à
l'alcool ou à d'autres types de drogues
des trucs domaine généralement cette
phase lorsque ça veut dire c'est que on
et off de façon variable
tu vas avoir des épisodes de beaucoup
d'anxiété des épisodes dépressifs des
épisodes où tu as l'impression que même
certains des effets négatifs toute
indépendance son come back m'étais
agente en 8x
puis c'est cela c'est ça je pense le
truc it off pour pour
le défilé s'est arrêté quelque chose
pendant des années les habitudes de vie
de ces faits mettant moi c'est ça ma
position là dessus c'est vraiment que
faut pas le banaliser pas ce que clame
développer une dépendance au cannabis
très difficile de s'en débarrasser mais
si pour toutes les personnes en deuil
qui sont là dedans puis qui sont pas
rendus au stade où comme s'est terminé
bien comme senna est spacieux de plus en
plus d'avenue de le faire comme plus
intelligemment que stupide toi tu as tu
déjà essayé d'arrêter comme maintenant à
plusieurs reprises puis c'est sa main
c'est vraiment été comme les viandes
arrive la musique ici comme un peu c'est
ce qu'ils disent que je jetais un petit
job malédiction les drogues douces entre
guillemets aussi parce que comme celle
là je suis dans mal en ce moment qu'elle
s'est arrêtée puis quand j'étais dessus
c'est à dire cette zone
c'était comme acquis au teint de
changement tant de restructuration
d'habitude tout pour qui tout est
possible gérard perdu média 6 à
l'autriche comme si je suis en train de
faire entrer comme profondément illégal
profondément dartigeas comme ça devient
tellement facile aussi des jeux se dit
bon je vais essayer notre chatte de
confiance plus excités parce que tout le
monde qui a déjà essayé comme un peu des
ti c'est vrai pas par la tête tirée par
rapport à bas les trucs puis final c'est
que c'est vrai que c'est tout le
dangereux tir mais son marché le long
terme fait qu'un court terme je me sera
pas uniquement à mon corps jusque ya pas
d artistes pas noir ou blanc
c'est comme complètement sait quel genre
mais tant que susciter départ à quelque
chose comme c'est sûr que comme tu es en
train de vivre que du négatif m c'est
comme je trouve que c'est ce qu'il faut
des tabous y fit l'éthique qu'il faut
emmener pour justement que les gens se
sentent à l'aise après 2
enfin dépôt versus comme devoir faire
switch pourtant j'aime c'est le
raisonnement est le même de dire le
dukan s'est entraînée par un mois plan
mené sa trempe pas d'y aller tu dis
crise avant que je me donne ce défilé de
m'entraîner à tous les jours je mangeais
bien jeter fréquemment santé ma vie
allait bien même tarif pour une journée
à toi y arrive aussi que je me fais
chier à y aller tout leur ment ça
t'empêche pas d'être fonctionnel et
productive titre la musique pitié c'est
substance la samp la créativité ou
brimer mexique comme comme jeudi ses
supporteurs pour moi parce que mon
dernier référent devineau jo clotilde
comme ça va pas rester très longtemps
mais ton sang est là dessus tout c'est
comme j'avais 11 ans et comme fixé comme
même et je parle indiqué genre
fondamentalement je n'avais pas ce qui
était jusque là je prends pas ça c'est
juste c'est ça c'est ça oui elle a même
temps je sais comme j'en parle avec
beaucoup de légèreté passer ma propre
vie c'est juste que ja entache trouve ça
bien de pouvoir à la fois comme sans
gêne parler de tout ce qui est simple
équité pilote d'un peu comme chez air
mauritius le cje a justement je suis
trop bon à la glorification de tulle
et puis quand des fois je me rends
compte un peu peut-être que sa main
c'est que des fois on le fait un peu à
gauche à droite si j'osais kounta dollar
nettement le dessus de commandes il faut
faire attention exxon
têtu a en ce moment oui monsieur moi je
suis prêté reste souvent ma vie mais les
phocuswright programme de m'exprimer
comme si tu exprimes lol c'est
clairement sa nuit pata volubilité ce
n'est pas ta façon de l'exprimer
chercher des idées t'as pas l'air de
c'est moche et quand je parle depuis que
j'ai une idée qui me vient quand frei
si je la dis bon moment parce que je la
pense y est parti pour toujours le même
se souvenir d'avoir une bonne
qui est parti qui est irrécupérable
médias avaient menacé comme je t'aime je
te souhaite pas de pilote il est vrai
prochaine la journée environnement
familier comme appris à comme j'ai
ressenti ce serait un peu rincé cc66
comme les gens qui vivent ou peut-être
une analogie un peu de mal mais
maintenant qu'ils vivent en altitude au
pérou quand ils mangent des feuilles de
coca ils sentent pas comme où elle vit
il son jeu c'est normal comme le nouveau
chef c'est le cas d'affaires notre
journée de ce plan n'est pas comme des
facs et cc oui c'est ce que l'on
s'habitue tout comme la capacitation de
du corps humain mais bref il ya des
choses qui sont plus dangereuses que
d'autres à s'adapter c'est que la
justice à mettre ses intérêts c'est que
je veux juste rester là dessus comment
tu as commencé sa came as tu me dis à 11
ans qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui amène de
11 ans jusqu'à maintenant mais je dirais
que c'est comme c'est que j'imagine que
dépendamment des personnes il ya des
gens qui étaient prêts faire certains
types de sensations qui adore of corse
on a tous des gens de simuler
différentes vues différents types
il ya des gens par exemple qu'il aime
plus l'adrénaline qui drive c'est ce qui
fait que demande son dea durée nommé
john key pilotes sont comme gens disent
même pas prendre un manège même s'ils
savent si sécuritaire et ma peau et mai
puis bat il qu'un best-of procure des
sensations dans le cerveau ou des trucs
comme ce que le plus ton corps produit
pas ce truc là par lui-même
à ce moment le temps veut quand il veut
exactement entier puis bon il pas bonne
combinaison de raison que ton propre du
passé de ce puits que je pousse un petit
rythme et jean requête qui pourrait
balancer ce sens sans fumée aux côtés
jusqu'à ce qu'un des jeunes domaine puis
dans le fond sur les api comme chez jane
com
pas trop pourquoi mais comme des chats
mais il ya des chances a nettement que
j'étais dans une situation où ça ça
jouer un peu un rôle de vitamines par
rapport à quelque chose des gens par
rapport à ces j'ai toujours été un peu
et par actif comme des tendances à
l'anxiété des choses comme ça c'est
clair que ça calme ne sache à quel
moment ça comme un peu sa chatte dans
une partie de ce que je pourrais appeler
comme le white noise de la ville
c'est des choses comme ça puis en même
temps j'étais comme ça j'ai mais le côté
aussi de disco active c'est déjà un choc
mon cerveau est comme stimuler
présentement en tiges en jeu
j'avais envie pige à ce jeu quand çà
cette eau a comme cache des jeunes au
lieu de métaux famille picom juste mais
j'ai pas même très beauf une blague est
une émission mais j'aimais j'aimais ce
qu'on écrit les tic comme je vous ai
chétif à des affaires comme si le fait
que ça ça a joué un peu ce rôle depuis
je pense que j'étais bien trop jeunes
puis aussi comme la société aujourd'hui
un kit qui reste ces réactions peut-être
que comme il ya la grande virée du gang
et ses raids en quarts et 6-4 en guise
c'est à dire qui sont ces quelques qu'
il y aura peut-être si on est flou ça
mettons la sérotonine et la dopamine qui
produit naturellement avec le sport et
l'alimentation a peut-être qui va moins
c'est comme trip et autant que puis ça
me fait penser à une expérience qui
était fédéraux en fait c'est qu'ils se
sont intéressés à comment les
les réagissent aux tâches et puis il y à
bien comme deux groupes un groupe que
goûter à du péage type qui en a consommé
quand c'était des jeunes ron enfant puis
un autre qui en a juste goûter à l'âge
adulte restée comment développer et puis
ceux qui ont seulement goûter à l'âge
adulte quand ce texte contesté comment
développer s'il y avait comme curiosité
ils essayent comme j'en ai peut-être un
ou deux qui reste un métier comme hiver
comme peu fou ex mettant ces gens puis
l'autre groupe ce qui avait goûté à ce
qu'un ces jeunes qui comme ça ils ont
comme chez briand bien mignon non plus
repris
il représente la substance à l'âge
adulte yves est repoussée comme un
handicap auteurs veulent fréquenter
comme il aime ce pays ils sont sont
prêts à fournir des efforts pour
l'obtenez différence que m cette
expérience moi j'ai comme la nation fait
que
7 6 6 6 je souhaite surtout pas présenté
l'idée que dans le fond c'est de
commencer je ne sais pas mais non plus
comme pas dupe au stade où j'en ch la
mcit fait c'est sûr et certain que comme
il faut absolument qu'on peut être non
je suis comme si j'essaie de jeu
j'essaie d'avoir une certaine forme de
patience parce que c'est comme ça c'est
la vie compliquée quelque chose comme ce
qui certainement mais il ya des manières
d'augmenter l'offre de et il ya des
études maintenant aussi qui demande que
tu as causé mille jeunes ça peut être
développer nos cerveaux 25 ans on entend
que je pense vraiment gouvernement ils
pensent maintenant c'est la limite d'âge
à 21 plutôt fait toi qu'est ce que tu
penses de tss est ce que tu dirais je
sais pas comment dire mais ce qui est ce
que tu dis ouais j'aurais peut-être dû à
temps double incident tas dont une
évolution ça a été un chemin qui est qui
et qui a valu à peine d'être pris le cpo
voyage je regrette pas si je regrette
vraiment pas au sens où difficile c'est
la vie que je mène que si je le mets
mais comme c'est clairement je pense que
dans un autre univers notre époque de
kits j'aurais bien gérée bénéficient
plutôt d'avoir d'avoir au lieu d'avoir
une approche plus comme un vrai pro
bâtiment sa petite enveloppe admis à
l'école mes parents ni à la société
c'est comme un peu et elle est surtout
dans les années 90 comme ça j'espère la
seule approche qui avait litige sur tes
parents sont bien funky
il fait toujours des batailles qu'on
soit évidemment sont trop bas down c'est
simplement que si je suis un peu ce qui
seules six personnes et faisait
peut-être que dans le fond ça répond à
des besoins qu'on ne soupçonne pas
peut-être constante et peut-être que
l'enfant sans le savoir est en train de
s'auto médicamenté des tendances de
d'anxiété épisodes de 10
activité puis comme il sait même pas
piller rendu dans une forme de
pharmacologie personnel sur la réalité
de ces faits que fais je suis dans en
titi avec l'éducation sur la chose
fournit déjà que que dans les écoles au
lieu d'avoir une approche sauveteurs sur
la question et nos projets éducatifs
c'est parce que y'a rien selon qui est
plus comme non constructif pour inquiète
que lorsqu'il réalise qui sait comme
fait mentir sur certaines choses par
rapport aux dangers de ces enfants leur
billet comme hockey dans le fond vaut
avertissement c'est toute la manche
c'est quand même ça puis c'est normal
qu'ils étaient cette réaction le 15 août
et quand on te dire d'autre a ajouté
thibault futur de virer fou pitié comme
c'est sur sa vie risque est plein dans
le monde font que prince aux seychelles
le fait d'en parler avec une approche
scientifique je pense la meilleure app
swing la répression ça peut avoir un
effet aussi persuasif le tir dans le
fond je m'en empêcher ben occulter ce
tuto plutôt que je t'aime à l'éducation
puis non sommation mais comme c'est moi
comment j'ai commencé parce que c'est
super simple petit c'est à dire que jean
allard écrit à l'école où sont leurs
biens il ya toujours eu un doute qui
doit l'être aux high tech a besoin de
100 piasses puis à cette époque la tête
ashton 5 à 2 3 go j'ai amené 18 52
hockey il manque juste robert s'achètent
comme buffalo sabres et george hill tjcc
des enfants d'amérique
par contre en seconde avant il n'y avait
pas un doux d'un poète qui vendait de
l'alcool ce que je faisais moi je suis
pas mal persuadé que plus ils égalisent
et puis plus et comme plus ces commandes
est non seulement légaliser normalisé
mettre dans le bon sens du terme pour
banaliser mais normaliser les gens - sas
pour logiquement que ça sera mars en
comme des mains de qui j'étais actif et
claude jorion oui liquides sont bons
pour se reposer
quant au cru qu'il faut pas fumer mais
ça risque d'être nettement plus
compliqué à trouver scénaristique parce
que j'ai au moins ses veines c'est fou
lotis
les colts il par la pause du midi dans
l'école la sefac une salle principale un
toilette boj pourrait être le pire c'est
qu'il y en avoir passé sa toilette
après je pense à l'école ça se passe à
l'école puis moi tout ni panne est qui
qui qui a commencé à fumer de base aos
tendance à toujours été quelqu'un déjà
jusqu'à peindre au cégep lors on a
d'autres plus vieux litige paquin puis à
l'écran depuis que je sens la pâte en
face de chez eux puis le petit plus com
dcom comme la dynamique plus adultes un
peu de ses chats mais dans les écoles ça
passe systématiquement par un kid qui en
fait un jeune adolescent qui vend de
tout et un ami quittaient dos et puis
c'était de la merde pour ce qui est de
la hausse il commence alors basculer la
personne qui donne je prends une bonne
personne à encadrer un enfant de matinée
patrick irresponsable de déjà collaboré
à ce qu'un car kit de 14 ans c'est un
peu comme au baseball à 14 ans citons
hautes chaumes de 14 ans qui fait ça
c'était pas dans ce n'est pas une potion
comme le levier moral
y avait des gars car le scooter à 14 ans
louise lahaye c'est clair mais tout à
voir podcast ex bois prestement pas
d'alcool dans le fond moi ce que je
t'avais existe entre guillemets c'est à
ces méthodes c'est pas mal ce n'est
jamais une relation pragmatique avec
l'alcool t'es jamais j'avais pris
beaucoup j'aime j'ai jamais le même
temps que mse même année c'est juste
arrivé dans la zone jeter comme puis
comme je vous disais à propos des buts
c'est comme dans mon milieu
professionnel la plupart du temps quand
j'étais en train de travailler d'alcool
gratuit a aussi fixé comme un peu ses
chicanes ma caisse et si j'étais j'ai
clairement des tendances où je peux
développer comme si jamais je t'ai
l'alcool je peux pas mal plus peur que
je trouve que je me souhaite vraiment
pas maintenant de développer une
mauvaise relation avec sur toutes les
trois accessible pour indépendants c'est
trop axé sur ce que je fais tu fais ton
juste entre justement un peu dans un
esprit de bayti t'inkiet jo je choisis
mes vestes choisi mais quand bob ceci vu
que je peins je le vis pas comme si je
me pris je le vis pas comme une
privation pour personne que je le dis
maintenant légalisée mais à l'époque je
te manquer on n'a pas vraiment pas la
même attitude justement avoir un jeune
femme spot versus péter harling fait
petit bois l'alcool ou non plus le
métier juste juste latitude mais toi tu
regardes style le podcast john logan a
fait avec elmo ce système a bâti c'est
la consternation totale c'est comme
premièrement c'est les gars californie
deuxièmement et guy boivin du cognac
tout le long de podcasts des personnes
investies mot là dessus mais il ya du
club acception pis c'est quand
camdessus pas vraiment les pour et les
contre l'alcool et d'une rue prendra
bien plus néfaste le cpie ben plus
meurtrière dans la dans la consommation
appuyer ce je pense que c'est
objectivement un vrai mais l'alcool par
contre comparable un no drugs quelles
séquelles une zone grise plus grande de
comme entrant en même temps que souhaite
afic
ce que peu de drogue tous cas pour
d'autres dragons c'est gentil ça tu
prends une petite quantité de gens qui
demandent n'importe quoi péter qu'en mai
les bases solides affectés louise
généralement ça c'est la première pole
qui bossent bien plus que les autres
comme si ça ajoute des meilleurs mais
comme le bon gros les yeux c'est la
première peuvent laisser cela lequel se
trouve pas ça se prend une gorgée alcool
déjà tu peux clairement plus facilement
de sciences sociales l'alpha puis que tu
étais même pas affecter ses fictions ce
comme normal en même temps qu'est comme
betty l'alcool peut à la fois est une
des drogues et plus banal au mans mais
bizarrement aussi l'aillerie partie
comme sans trop exagérer non plus à
étapes de quoi passer un accord c'est
comme tout le monde j'ai vu quelqu'un
s'est passé comme des gens qui sont
comme un pur vrai charme et 11,7 choses
que j'ai dites ou faites moi je pense je
l'aurais pas fait dit il
c'est comme si une excuse de marbre tout
le monde est d'accord s'excuse demande
mais je pense que on sait tout réveiller
un matin dans le pays un peu recruté ces
piges je pense que c'est par là mais moi
dans ma vie à mes temps j'ai pas vu
beaucoup mais ça m'est déjà arrivé de me
sentir comme ça par coeur mais ça mais
j'ai jamais je l'ait déjà utilisé
l'excusé bicycle a amassé jamais une
excuse à utiliser mais j'ai jamais eu
envie du excuses bats comme j'ai jamais
comme fait pyjama fait georges elle met
sur le dos de gentil quand on dirait que
ça c'est mon expérience dans
l'expérience de l'interrelation le porte
voix pop ou ch pas à franchir des
limites qui ne devrait pas franchir en
argent ou à des choses sexy comme comme
tindall overdose de potes c'est souvent
comme sur l'addition se refermer sans
dormait puis comme rien de glorieux
l'absolu mais jamais temps
l'ouvreuse d'alcool c'est vomir avoir
vraiment la tête potentiellement faire
un combo
c'est l'oeuvre d'al qods fixée c'est là
où c'est comme si on te dirai que ce
qu'on dit déjà
mais prendre un poste va être basé raid
prend une gorgée il ya plein de choses
qui se passent l'été
c'est comme cccc gens d'être clos 840
duc au parc puis pour faire le saut au
19 août pourquoi l'at aux dangers des
drogues d'autres choses dans
l'expérimentation que tu fais ou qui
étaient ces et piquer quelques thèmes
qui était une enfant mais une fois pas
deux j'ai jamais comme jamais mais c'est
quand même si j'ai eu des bons moments
là dessus si ç'a vraiment été des
moments de type chamanique téléphone à
reste ancré dans ma maman mais j'ai pas
besoin de revenir à chaud c'est exact et
puis j'oublie que ça existe ce genre
qu'elle vienne et des moments sûrement
exceptionnel ce que je trouve cool des
fois avec steam ou j'ai très peu
l'expérience des drogues métier j'ai
fait une drogue dure une fois cet homme
vraiment exceptionnel j'allais parler
sur un autre pas de casse le sait mais
justement ça devient une espèce de à qui
j'ai vécu une fois piste amara
demi-finale von spee puis c'est ce type
i le danger des dangers des drogues
c'est que ça devient excessif car c'est
devenu très ambitieux décrit comme un
one shot une fois où un super rare de 15
ans par spéciale c'est juste un petit
côté rituel à être beaucoup à ce titre
sera en béton
qu'est ce match les dragons jet est ici
par une culture à part dans le monde
actuel où les religieux ou festifs avril
d'encadrer comme d'avoir des conditions
en guillemets terre qu'il faut que ça
soit plein litige et sam et on sort
climatique
il faut par mois max et quand on s'en
fout là la marque est le dieu de la
pleine lune le permet
poulat jamais tant mieux en même temps
ce thème est le live at elle insisté
c'est l'incroyable s'est pas fait de
dérapage
moi je pense que consciemment et
inconsciemment les humains ont inventé
des histoires comme en été expliqué
gagne demande que je peux m'en est bon
pour ton fois maintenant d'exane
on est maintenant la gagne le tice tu
fais ça autrement qui a plein de
l'attention si ce contrôle des masses
avec des sports mais comme je pense que
des ritualiste beaucoup dans la société
les substances type puis on aurait
avantage à peut-être un peu tu es comme
s'informer aussi sur comment des gens
qui ont dû utiliser ces substances en
dehors d'un trip juste créatif et puis
pourquoi met-on commencé il ya des vieux
dude en inde
georges clemenceau comme de doux baisers
très bof mais pas la vie l'a vu à
méditer f medibat pourquoi ils font sur
le monde que ça fait cinq mille ans qui
font ce versus you checker comme un film
[Applaudissements]
exact si des traces d'alcool ou si tu
faisais quand elle qu'elle veut veut pas
c'est comme la drogue dans le sud
chrétien
il ya manière d'avoir ça autrement que
je sais qu'il boit deux défenseurs
qu'elle est les gens 24 ans le monde qui
font dans des abbayes d al qods comme ça
il est après ceux qui font leur alcool
dans la mecque ou siemens et d'un vieux
juif
d'être cool c'est un bon outil pour
rappeler au monde qui comme celle et les
bains qu'il faut ça crée déjà des
rituels comme sortie et puis quand à ne
pas c'est là où un peu entre un danger
qui vient réellement non j'ai juste une
façon de parler mais c'est plus une
réflexion au sens où c'est dans notre
société c'est vraiment eu chacun crise
irait propre rituel impression non
encore caixin convaincant fait en
gagnant même talent
ouais mais c'est comme noël la saint
valentin fête des jards des affaires un
peu comme ces mais sinon c'est comme
chacun pour soit le type même même temps
même famille il le dit c'est ta main
peur j'avais dans une compétition plus
de rituels commun on est rendu à une
époque où vraiment fait si tu t'en fais
pop qui n'est pas trois mois une
certaines balises va avant certaines
choses
il ya deux sociétés j'avais cette
réflexion là qu'un quand j'allais à
l'épicerie par moi même quand je suis
parti chez mes parents
jallet l'épicerie par moments mpt la
section gâteau aux aidants l'épicerie le
tu peux acheter un gâteau n'importe
quand si je voulais
j'aurais pu acheter un gâteau n'importe
quand quand j'ai réalisé cela j'ai fait
tabarnak faut bien que ce soit une
faillite pour que j'achète un sinon je
peux en acheter un tout avec celle à la
réflexion peut-être droit non je dois
attendre quelque chose de spécial parce
que sinon la mort à chaque jour chez
nous rien qui va m'empêcher c'est pas
illégal j'ai le droit de prendre le
gâteau même allé chez nous avec l'argent
c'est ma décision
puis ici serait questionner justement
sur les pourquoi tu mets toi tu es
quelqu'un qui fait mal chaque jour la
fine métier questionne toi sur le
pourquoi tu fais ce qu'est ce que ça
donne bharti et c'est apporter du
positif du négatif dans ta vie puis
j'essaie d'être lucide par rapport à ce
que c'est parce qu'il ya mené qu'à
l'habitude ça c'est des puces
requestionner là dessus je pense le fact
is the sphere ok on a tous des amis
justement quiquet qui consomment pitt
crime je pense soit que lui dans son
côté dispositif
ces factures juste deux quais près prend
arrêter deux secondes puis je dis tu as
it well as peut être ton habitude fait
qui s'est tu sais tu vraiment bon et
puis si c'est les frais l'été je sais je
sais être conscient c'est la musique se
connaître soi même si ses jambes taux de
change s'est fixé sur qui tu es moi je
me souhaite d'avoir des ddd retour des
remises en question mais je me souhaite
plus par contre d'avoir comme d'avoir
catégorisé comme déjà des affaires thé
ou de com de ou d'être dans une forme
d'urgence de performativité par rapport
à des trucs comme ça à moins que ma vie
devienne comme sévèrement affecté comme
des paravents papa je sais pas si en
danger ou une maladie où lé volume
sommet comme si je pense que la
stratégie de la tortue en général mène à
demain résultats que la stratégie du ps
et puis - ce qui moi ce qui m'a moins
aidé c'est un peu la culture entourera
la notion de l'arrêt de quelque chose
une culture très importante régie des
eaux qui comme j'ai personnes se
consciemment tête mais c'est un peu ce
finalement c'est à dire que comme les
allées assez littéralement et le jus qui
s'est littéralement religieux tea mais
comme il ya beaucoup beaucoup de la
culture de la désintox provient de des
hordes qui tendait comme qui est un des
premiers groupes que vraiment comme
publiciser l'existence de ce genre de
support group cette chère d'europe et de
la culture de la vie y est tellement de
positif là-dedans mais yossi je trouve
des fois des gens de jaune un peu de com
autoflagellation repentance comme jean
rejeté dans le mal maintenant je suis
dans le bien c'est que j'ai créé un mur
mais tu sais comme pitch tant mieux si
des personnes qui considèrent que c'est
ça a été ce qu'il fallait pour ruth et
depuis c'est comme qu'on puisse y
compris que seul le quart est
complètement c'est plus que honorable
il existe un peu trop noir ou blanc n'y
a pas tant de moralité et braqué dans ce
truc le chaud puis un peu trop de com
des il faut pas que ça soit tabou de
dire ben manifestement ça donnait aussi
quelque chose de positif ne soit autant
la balance et comme je le sais lol ne de
la question de ces gens se posent
siffloter du cas d'aller chercher autre
amant parce que si c'est juste négatif
par était juste débile c'est gentil
comme l'expliqué des milliers des
millions voire des milliards qui
[Musique]
auraient disparu donc tu arrêter de
perdre une partie toi tedeschi hippolyte
définie mais qui fait de quitter les
personnes qui étaient mes temps messi
wayne parce que c'est comme un peu c'est
pour une question c'est vrai c'est une
bonne question ça c'est pas la part de
perdre une partie de moi c'est comme
séquelle mais après sa part de paix
un bon vieil ami dont ouais ok c'est que
c'est comme un peu chat c'est bon vieil
ami c'est pas moi que je m'appelle bon
vieux chat c'est comme si je rentrais
projet lui avec des fois on comprend
tellement c'est cette fois que ça
m'arrivait de faire des pauses plus
longues sans fumée clairement 26 chiche
mon corps je lis commandes âgées les
rainmen pour qui comme les fois où j'en
ai appris lors qu'il ya quand même une
zone déjà tombé à mes revenus le voyage
s'est satisfait que c'est qu'un petit
ces référents la tête et en même temps
tu es comme des concerts c'est un temps
présenté comme il ya des zones
d'humilité la danse et qui sont qui sont
frappantes qu'ils peuvent
c'est moi je suis le type de personne
qui est plus jeune je n'en savais rien
que je pouvais pas faire je n'ai pas de
limites c'est que jean c'est bon d'avoir
des fois des lumières et du tchèque
déchetterie de kochi comme essayer forme
figée politique à batiscan comme dans
cet échec l'oeil de constater ce simple
aussi d'apprendre que comme à l'avenir
peut-être que ce n'est pas de voir si ça
marche pas si je vais m'en sortir mais
des fois ci le plus qu'à passer on
partira tout juste avant on parlait de
cet organe ses pieds
l'autre jour j'ai encore une entrevue de
seppi si je veux pas si tu regardes
c'est un gars qu'on associe à ses
pierres parlent ouvertement qu'il faut
le pro légalisation optique femmes à
chaque jour aux 8es et aucun tabou avec
ça mais ça fait comme partie de son
personnel mettons j'aime peu d'entrevues
autorisait je pense qu'avec l'école
colbert des films qu'on voit dans le
fond du litige
les cinq juges à mais pas geler leurs
cartons besoins d'un film
ja m c'est comme ça fait partie lui
c'est comme ils disent à son état normal
c'est exact et puis comme toi t'as qu'à
l'écouter déjà qu'on peut on peut
supposer même temps que des tests
étaient là
bah oui quoi bon sens où si tu peux
supposer j'étais jolie part parce que
j'entends pas fake c'est sale et les
lèches pas la clé du truc
ou plutôt le deuil de tout seul comme un
peu sortir des ddd des tranchées des
hommes où on se fait la gare entre comme
moi je pense que si j'avais été plus vif
plus jeune j'avais vu plus de de marge
de manoeuvre pour explorer sur cinq soit
jusqu'au bout juste les samoa même où
comme vous n'êtes en plus démoniser à
traces quant aux hormones que je répète
un peu plus notre approche c'est comme
ça serait fou de penser que j'avais
développé exactement la même à patates
que oui mais je fais que c'est ce que
c'est un questionnement de société lov
côté fiction moi je salue t il y en ai
demandé mais les intrus que j'aurais
fait différemment dans la logique finale
au final tous les détails plus
techniques logistiques de comment ça
s'est passé particulièrement par rapport
à ce qu'ils disent au québec mais à la
base je salue fonda le premier plus gros
pas dans la bonne direction
et puis ça risque même selon moi d'avoir
des effets secondaires positifs sur
d'autres types de drogues d'autres ces
précautions qui sont même pas encore
légal
c'est à dire que j'ai rajouté un peu
comme c'est toute la société canadienne
québécoise vient de passer à travers
comme une aventure mental ou comme un
truc jusqu'à postillons taxant démoniser
collective l'insolence et rien qui était
vraiment fait rire c'est se fermer
ya pas eu un problème vraiment 16e pas
eu de répercussion nominatives
rien on n'est pas dans une histoire
passée de camille c'est pire qu'avant
est-ce que les gens consomment plus
qu'avant j'ai des gros doutes là dessus
les gens consommaient des jeux s'est
jusque là c'est mieux encadré qui savait
que j'étais déjà j'espère qu'on se
souvient consomment moins mais je pense
que j'en consomme mieux c'est ça la
seule elle tout à fait faire seulement
le point important c'est puis je pense
qu'après une couple d'années au pouvoir
le mesurer myocarde mais je sais que mes
temps aux pays bas amsterdam
ils ont ils ont remarqué que depuis
qu'il avait légalisé en imprégner à long
terme ça va entraîner comme une quand
même pas une énorme je pense une comme
faible diminution de la consommation de
la population générale
je pense que la place où c'est le plus
frappant c'est au portugal qui ont
dynamisé le jeu passe pratiquement
toutes les drogues qui avait des gros
problèmes de dos des drogues fortes qui
ont des doutes des crimes décriminaliser
il ya une grosse grosse gros changement
sur les taux de décès des paroles aux
grosses grosses basses tpiy au final
quelqu'un d'indépendant
c'est pas une criminelle c'est juste
quelqu'un qui a besoin d'en élire
quelqu'un qui sait quelqu'un qui est
dans le cadre à mars à sortir de cette
maladie le retard sur deux des gros
problème c'est qu'on va t'en va t'en à
thônes finale b au stade
au point où j'en sais que oui tu un
membre officiel après après c'est ce
qu'il faut le légaliser
c'est parce qu'une nuance à
décriminaliser illégalisé maintenant il
faut légaliser toutes les drogues
je ne sais pas est-ce qu'il faut
criminaliser le départ d'acquis que j'ai
besoin justement d'un coup de main je
pense vraiment potes mais je me rappelle
que quand on était au primaire de
l'alcool à l'école saint-roch à québec
puis si elle a fait rêver gilles kègle
rock après année il y avait un prof qui
avait dit qu'à saint roch y avait des
piqueries puis j'ai été élevé dans un
milieu ultra conservateur le film que
j'avais entendu ça qui avait décrit mon
argent je comprenais pas de cette espèce
d'image l'est resté avec moi vraiment
longtemps puis plus je vieillissais plus
à me revenaient des fois mettront
peut-être pas trois fois quatre fois par
année maintenant
cette image là je me dis tabarnak plus
je vieillis plus je comprenais plus
l'espèce de dichotomie dans ma tête
entre le bien et le mal de venait juste
se disent floués au milieu il ya
quelqu'un qui ont un problème avec
quelque chose qui peut les gars qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec cette personne mais
est ce que on fait juste dire attendez
que t'es pas les toniques ce qu'est ce
que ce kit comprend un pôle égalité
juste illégal ou bien on fait on dit
cheikh
on va s'assurer que ce que tu fais dans
ta vie tu le fasses pour que ça nuise le
moins possible à toi et à tout le monde
pour toi oui c'est raisonnable comme il
ya comme fait du chemin et vraiment
longtemps matin puis maintenant c'est
exquis soir à l'égalisation puis on a
parlé si on légalisait de claix drogue
au québec puis comme de fait on dit si
c'est tellement pas noir ou blanc cette
question loeb c'est tellement important
dans le cadre des gens qui ont
réellement des problèmes puis depuis le
petit moi qui étais assez rock qui avait
fait voyons dans avec des reculs c'était
quand même trash death ride
ce petit manège de jeu pile protat n'ai
pas trop joué le pire c'est quand il est
utilisé au moins sept des comptes au
moins le protéger je content d'avoir eu
parce que c'est drôle parce que si nous
votons tallec au sérieux parce qu'ils
aiment le sport études qui ont fait la
natation c'est moi mais je partais de
l'école à céleri les gens très belle
école men parfaite le petit quartier
parfait était pile et on arrive à ça ira
depuis c'est comme acquis il ya une
réalité autre qui exige je suis
réellement content d'avoir eu la ticad
d'enfance de jean louis petit chèque de
acquis à manille manager ce mardi midi
on va on allait manger comme au centre
écrit assez flou bah justement la cour
du sahara etc puis il ya un gars
complètement pasteur dans le milieu du
parc maxime ci dessus c'est kiki c'est
comme ça
vu ce que j'écris ce cri semaine c'est
un bon bassin peut attendre qu'ils
méditent ils sont d'abord maintenant
avant pis surtout de notre milieu
mais oui si ce n'est on était on était
quand même à cuire d'argent ce qui
m'amène à parler de la classe la
relation quand la clubic week parce que
saint roch c'est quand même important
bah oui c'est important à l'agenda les
kits mais aussi comme ce que c'est
surtout à québec pour la culture urbaine
c'est vraiment beaucoup là que ça se
passe dans les quartiers comme qui fait
vivre plus de projet culturel urbain
en fait je pense qu'elle est et ce qui
est le paradoxe est qu à t on enfin
jackson aucun de nous vient de leur
chagrin qui m'attend mais c'est juste
que c'est quand même si comme le site is
toutes les chokotoffs 7 avril c'est
justin joue moins chez reebok acheté
plus jeunes pas mal à saint roch
mais oui oui d'esteban c'est comme je
pense que c'est comme le quartier le
plus savoir moi le plus comme
significatifs culturel plus
bouillonnants men de la culture roumaine
dacia vraiment parce que sinon tu t'en
vas en périphérie mettons que c'est un
beau geste à cette fois c'est vraiment
plus universitaire tu es là même la
haute ville c'est plus c'est plus ce
club c'est plus ce sourire entre l'élite
et la ville s'est énormément je sais
comment haddad
je pense que je pense entre autres à mon
cas si timo glock la population beaucoup
vieilli 1,36 les loyers augmentent et
j'étais votre c'est là la carte is a
joke brasse un peu plus en matière comme
plus une artère chili c'est comme si
encore des transports sauf car ce métier
là c'est 100% c'est rock ça c'était une
personne qui cherche à avoir du fun à
voir une expérience de nuit qui est
intéressante c'est saint joseph s'est
lui même libéré on a vu un institut
allemand sur cinq chiffres ces derniers
y avait le cercle celtique de place le
fun c'est pau pour la culture ou encore
le bout des ongles le boudoir et il y
avait c'est maintenant sur saint-joseph
tu vois que c'est là chez paul espèce de
clientèle type de la grande allée qui
rentrent leur plus grande allée je viens
douce et les touristes
mais sa vraie place à des passes ou le
temps fuit vers le rsa ça vaut aussi
petit comme aussi comme tout les mois
loupé ça souvent plus que jamais tiens
comme c'est moi je pense que c'est on
attend beaucoup de trucs sur québec
malheureusement défaut d'être c'est vrai
souvent les plus gros joueurs sans
talent c'est 6
quand on connaît un peu le temps que le
québec
mais même temps il ya quelques piques
c'est pas qu'ils se rendent malheureux
qui font pas autant de bruit
malheureusement métiers qui font qu'ils
créent plus le fait du québec c'est ça
c'est comme une tique sur six membres
dans laquelle il y en a cinq qui
viennent de l'eure qui ont grandi là bas
me toujours un minimum trop ou même 4
qui vivent à quelqu'un d'encore plus de
tout début de mois watts kane pis claude
on s'est échangé les rôles des
montréalais le bio des terres avec
marianne on est à montréal mois le
chameau gallois temps à moi ferons du
bac c'est que la moyenne historique de
la classe et 3 montréal 3 3 qui est ce
que ça complique la la la dynamique de
travail ou pas partir
sa présence sa soeur créé des conditions
différentes qui ont des défis mais aussi
des bons côtés
c'est ce qu'il sait quel genre à cause
de cela car on a dû développer beaucoup
de confiance en la méthode de
l'improvisation à la méthode comme
on sera pas tout le monde la sait
exactement où en est on on peut pas
vraiment faire une pratique cette
semaine avant le show c'est comme ci
comme ça voire de vote à l'erreur au
petit comme comme difficile des
pratiques mais l'eee pad justement parce
que mettons qu'on avait été les six
dents mais m'vila habitait à quelques
démarches l'un de l'autre depuis forever
vraiment qui a mené dix convois orient
dit comme ça peut être une très bonne
chose mais ça oriente à long terme
toutes les cotes comment laban
fonctionner tout à fait qu'on ne font
que ça nous nous écrit les
environnements où
on se familiariser avec certaines
méthodes qui nous sont propres en
mettant ça sinon je connais pas beaucoup
d'autres banques
c'est sûr qu'il y en a d'autres mais qui
n'ont jamais ou presque c'est très rare
qu'on incite les branches qui je sais
pas c'est quoi être comment faire quand
on joue comme en ski quand les chefs des
quatre faces après puisse apporter fait
ok ça puisse comme lui qui tente le pour
être comme une technique quand une
technique un peu ya pas eu d enfant un
garçon né déjà shit c'est comme quand on
a parfois le temps ça me fait développer
ce genre de méthodes qui ont fait comme
rijeka du baladin châtiés comme nos
jackman départ de cette liste a fait en
sorte que t'as pas le choix tu qu'on est
un peu plus de tonnes que je sais que
tous ceux qui vont jouer devant puis que
même au choix d'avoir un dialogue avec
la foule aussi exactement c'est à dire
qu'il y en a 1 puis c'est lui qui était
celui qui moins occupés à courir partout
fait que l'espace de comme avant plus
une vidéo sans faire qu'ils et le
croassement il réagit comme si je pense
que le maire coup en ce moment ça serait
sopi moi j'ai pas eu le temps de penser
différemment en mode et dj c'est tanguy
mais dans le fond ce qui inquiète ce
qu'on trouve si normal qu'un dj face
choisissent les imaginales dj fait ok je
m'en viens jouer la gagne puis ces
sommes sont bons c'est ce qu'a expliqué
des calices le sait jamais comme des
loques pour jouer le jet et versus c'est
que le problème avec ça c'est que c'est
une stratégie qui est beaucoup plus de
serre à faire lorsque étaient des
instruments sur scène était évidemment
fait que nous on utilise la réalité de
drap comme un laptop et de microdata ça
ouvre la porte à ses pieds nous on aime
on a beaucoup aimé cette méthode là des
gens comme ça nous a menés à des places
ou
ou justement comment un dj de seacom qui
tu le tiens un pied le dégel ses effets
comme ici qu'achille of state chaîne
j'ai fait une bonne sélection où je
trouve ça j'étais je prends la turquie
quand même et on publie ces mêmes
principes c'est des fois des partis
flamands
faites vous quand même un petit caucus
avant question mise en scène gérard et
claude chossat tels moments comme ça
mais jamais céder c'est justement ça
aussi cathy est un gros gros show de
l'entente qu'on le sien maintenant
plusieurs mois que vraiment on s'amuse à
10 fois penser à ces affaires le plus à
l'avancé peu comme ça mais c'est aussi
dans la démultiplication des choses mais
n'est-ce pas vrai que pour chaque chose
comme le respect c'est exact c'est plus
comme on commet répertoire de trucs
qu'on connaît avec lesquels on est
familier qu'on est capable de refaire de
façon improvisée que ça ressemble
beaucoup à comme l'autre fois qu'on le
fait mais c'était en utilisant que les
nouveaux éléments ici et chez eux puis
en même temps quelqu'un qui serait venu
voir tout les shows dans la claire à
travers toutes les plans sorties comme
flamands y aurait vu des choses qui
certains des patins c'est normal mais
comme je pense quand même que je
pourrais dire il y avait quand même vu
un genre de show unique à chaque fois
qui fait que c'est oui parce que c'est
comme un côté positif qui quand même qui
provient quand même de la difficulté
d'être c'est exact c'est une restriction
de la force à faire un choix créatifs
saissac réussite est liée pas de à la
classe avant une bibitte comme il y en
existe pas on dirait une espèce de
collectifs de gens qui sont pas tout le
temps là tout le temps tout le monde il
semble être issus d'univers différents
si j'avais tout votre justement votre
couleur mais vous apporter de quoi de
spécial
des trucs différents aussi mais quand ça
se passe c'est chez moi je te parlais 4
avril est illicite et la carte blanche
de jay du temple of duty 4
là mais comme qui arrive locke wilaya
comme l'est le segment haut parce que
jira pouces
rochât là je trouve ça malades
pourraient choquer je trouve c'est
vraiment un show c'est un projet qui est
quand même riche puis ça fait partie
aussi du vrai que ça fait partie du
folklore au québec
surtout que vous êtes clairement un
souci de vous inscrire dans le québec
dans l'histoire et vous ça paraît vous
connaissez votre torse après que vous
savez exactement c'est quoi votre place
là dedans puis vous jouez avec avec
c'est avec ces images il est ex aequo le
dilemme quand une profondeur et comment
un bagage qui vient car la classe tout
juste dans le titre le thé à la classe c
comme telle une étude nationale dans le
fond québec laissé la claire fontaine
seppi jacques fait coincer si c'est le
fun se soucie le 2d purement québécois
et canadien mais je te fait sentir
jusque canadien en dit long sur son
implication
c'est comme un peu moi je me suis
toujours excité à l'idée de l'engager
chauss'expo source est un concept né ça
existe c'est à dire qui comme comme
toute forme d'art communiqué
profondément des affaires sur sa société
tu peux apprendre pas mal plus de choses
sur les bons et les moins bons côtés
mais de la société américaine en
écoutant tout démarre demain de miley
cyrus qu'un écouta comme la poésie
engagée de quelqu'un qui dit que le
système c'est à dire que c'est toujours
toujours la réflexion coûte maintenant
sound amarres d'un ricky dee jay ceux
qui comme viva est riche actuellement
comme opinion mais tu vois qu'il ya
comme comme il 150 millions jose luis
scola et milliardaires avec cet anti
crise mis au courant j'ai dit ok je suis
en train de faire de l'art engagé parce
qu'ils m'offrent vraiment la possibilité
de réfléchir sur facebook
et ça paye ou le ticket ce qui est de
l'or qui te fait réfléchir au poste
c'est toujours un contexte social
chacune des oeuvres qui existent il
suffit d'avoir étudié la musique telle
enfants j'ai fêté mon célèbre université
en musique pythie l'ico de théâtre
musical justement paie pas de la période
qui tu étudies peu importe le style peu
importe quoi si jamais tu vas voir la
musique séparer de son contexte c'est
indissociable de toujours des parallèles
entre il passait pratiquement voici le
reflet dans la musique voici voici tcg à
l'époque du capitalisme sauvage matin
cette aubaine mais d'un autre côté
battle rap qui comme des démonstrations
c'est comme pau tourmalet meuf coche une
bonne partie du rap fait la célébration
du capital one et c'est pas plus
compliqué que ça le trafic sexy comme
fait loin d'andy vraiment beaucoup
châssis visage dans l'américaine puis
comme pas de sas de son expérience à
ceux ci étaient rivés sur l'observation
ci s'est effectué à moi je n'aime pas
l'idée de comme un peu il y réaliser des
thèmes c'est de dire mettons ce thème le
serait plus important qu'un autre s'est
fait un truc que j'ai toujours aimé chez
alaclair d'appui consent tout ça laisse
des trous justement de différents
milieux
mais d'abord différentes visions sur
différentes choses parce qu'au final ce
comme si oui si on parle du bas canada
on parle de l'entité si on parle de
l'histoire et ses hommes mais aussi on
parle de 20 des trucs d'agencés des
charges puis même pas des drus tu
t'attends mais comme on parle de boeuf
de boutiques de souvenirs entre amis de
rochestie puis tout ça et plus ou moins
important qu'un hôtel c'est pisser le
fait que je pense que c'est quand
justement tu donnes le dfid illustrer un
peu la variété des thèmes dans ta vie
puis dans ton bande am et on quitte eu
plus de chance justement de donner une
image intéressante de la société qu'elle
tu vis du versus comme ok oui tout c'est
à paris que je fais parce que je pense
mais je meurs focus est juste cette
opinion le pied contre ma musique voit
juste cet avion la fera passer
l'atelier pas de mauvaise foi là dedans
lapize gros respect aux gens qui
choisissent une idée qui fonce ne pas
m'aimer comme j'aimerais ça des fois
entendre comme la tonne dire mettons et
certains artistes qui sont du coup à
propos de toujours présenter une opinion
moral puis vertueuse dans leur truc mais
spécifiquement ces artistes ne serait
vraiment curieux d'entendre leur tour où
il envoie chier tout le monde
précisément curieux de savoir quand
elles sont pas dans leur personnage de
chute où le temps concernées par mes
impératifs moraux parce que personne
n'est qu'en fin dans le monde constitue
pas un récit déjà sur cette intéressante
il a déjà c'est le blog se pencher là
dessus comme carte et son style chinois
comme huawei puis c'était un être humain
comme tout le monde s'est tu vas chier
comme tout le monde
toutes les mères afin d'avoir un aperçu
sur le sait pas mais un aspect plus
viral ou plus primaire d'une personne
mais aussi tout aussi intéressant que
que les grandes idées mais tant pis si
je pense que c'est pour ça qu'on a qu'on
a utilisé un peu le symbole du
bas-canada au final ceci pour dire que
je peins comme on parle de de tout ce
qui peut avoir lieu ici sharks régime
c'est dans ce cas autant de la
géographie de la nature qui a des amis
et de la famille de la politique comme
ce que si ça se passe dans le bob et
otis comme star est un sujet qui nous
intéresse et puis c'est drôle parce que
c'est devenu carrément le le symbole
plus comme des ratés par rapport à
à la clarté comme le symbole du benz est
plus que prête à faire de même
ou comme à la base c'était pesant la
joke où le concept principal d'un drame
en boxe il est devenu en quelque sorte
répit je pense que les jeunes ou pour
pas juste les jeunes mais je pense que
six comme c'est un thème récurrent dans
la société québécoise qu'on étale a
parfois la recherche d'une identité de
se retrouver de se retrouver le quai
tzipi comme selon moi il n'y a pas de
réponse fixe déjà pré existante aux
faucons graz et 19
on invente au fur et à mesure et puis
comme on dit on n'a pas le choix du legs
le bailliage quillan ou puis on n'a pas
le choix d'en inventer de nouveaux
secteurs
c'est sûr que c'est ce que tu es
c'est ce que nous on s'amuse à faire
jean py permis parmi les symboles qui
était dans le fond le cedi le symbole
c'est la feuille du bop it sopi est ce
que parmi les idées que j'avais avancé à
ce qui m'attend ce symbole leur accoler
parce que vous l'avez choisie ou parce
que malgré vous malgré une quoi que ce
soit c'est ce que c'est ce qui résonnait
comme dans l'temps où les locaux ou les
maires souhaité dans l'expression qui
colle t est ce que c'est parce qu'il ya
une réception a fait chez à la clé le
test ultime par rapport avec le concept
inside expression école est ce qu'elle
voit comme souhaité c'est comme une
jarre de ces la sélection naturelle ccf
que c'est le club qui décide en bout de
ligne non c'est nous ah c'est vous gay
mais on décide c'est à dire que si une
expression survie a comme un ou deux
mois de temps comme de running gag
le running gag entre nous si le running
gag est rendu réel entre nous ici
l'expression une existence on se rend
compte que là on n'est plus en train de
faire exprès de le dire on demand
c'est comme les mains c'est exactement
la rencontre était impatient va-t-on de
choc émotif
bref des affaires de même comme les gars
commencent à m'appeler robert nelson
c'est parce que comme c'est lui qui a
déclaré l'indépendance du bas canada
puis le c'est moi qui a amené un peu
plus le côté gestion à ce moment là dans
les débuts d'un lac l'affectif mais
comme le sel à joe kelly comme appellera
bas le mois 600 mg appelé tellement
comme ça que je vais je pas choisissez
pause s'impose comme on est des fois non
il ya comme une mode passagère
les gamers inside qui s'essaye pigeât
ils deviennent report vous êtes les
filtres qui fait que quand ça colle ça
va coller ou pour le public aussi parce
qu'ils sont là votre rêve d'enfant oui
puis pour être avec toi
dallas dans l'écosystème à la clé dans
la van damme et ombres c'est pas juste
lui que safran cela m'éclate je pense
que m allait probablement rayé lui qui
par sa verve aux motrices légendaire ont
le plus d'impact au final ccma litres
est une expression filet
on lui fait le plus c'est comme 15 ne
sera pas le cas
si j'aimerais être un petit oiseau plus
pauvres ceux qui gagnent 2,6 g semble
tellement avoir d'insight fille de john
c c'est un autre famille événement
silence aussi pour ce qui est des modes
beaucoup de go dans le bain des enfants
ces quatre sur six tout ce qui compte la
famille exact mais comme la famille dans
son sens large c'est quand on était
clairement des amis à la base ajoute le
meilleur professionnel on est aussi des
musiques collègues éventuellement
devient comme la famille pour ouvrir le
sens où ces cgv c'est les seuls autres
personnes à qui j'ai vécu au tas de 2
ticks que c'est comme justement ma
famille directement
est-ce que parfois justement cette
relation-là peut devenir sans doute
après des années ait les six grosses
sommes ça peut pas être tout le temps
parfait mais rien de parfait je pense
dans le monde mais comme comment disait
on
je pense que quelque chose qui est clair
pour tout le monde puisse a jamais été
un tabou entre nous c'est que quand
vanessa ne tenterai plus de face à vous
était pas question qu'on allait faire ce
juste alimentaire mais c'est comme ça
juste parce que ben ça nous a donné bien
que ça soit sauf final je préfère faire
ce que notre job est en fait foi qui est
l'album que vous allez faire
alimentairement il serait pas vraiment
pas bon puis on leur prend le mans pau
si on ne reporte phone
enfin ça c'est pierre la classe à cause
que ce n'est justement si on et blesse
la nettement ses promesses ce qui a fait
en sorte que toute notre attitude a été
celle qu'ont eue pendant les dix années
c'est que l'origine du projet je t'ai
pour complètement mais peut-être un
petit peu une écoeurantite des projets
sérieux musique ok piste est comme fuck
toute seule fois que les reculs dus aux
phoques avoir une ambition qui essaient
de vivre de la musique tout ça on a
besoin de jeu se retourner au stade on
s'amuse en chameau studio d'âcre aucun
plan match
aucun panache comme concret en tête puis
a mené en une quinzaine de thoune
puissance au pire on s'en fout
comprenant le jeu typique se sait ça
c'est ce geste le fait marignagne des
personnes que il y avait plusieurs
personnes un groupe qui avait déjà en
disques et des trucs sérieux team fait
de façon beaucoup plus haut fait chaud
au final c'est le projet le plus donghae
vue qui comme au le plus d'impact jambes
elle s'amuse à obliger dit ok comme
mieux quelque chose on va pas on va pas
tout le temps ait dont vivent à cent
pour cent mais faut toujours se souvenir
de ce grand magic lui et son téléphone
la liberté ces sommes
celui qui travaille parfois c'était quoi
j'ai l'impression que c'est souvent
comme ça c'est ont leur suffit ici
pythie gaye estime john terry c'est pour
rire font ça pour le fun seppi c'est ce
qui marche très pique quand tu es trop
sérieux dans sa démarche car si vous
trouvez ce calcul trop juste par ses
seuls ceux qui étaient chez man avec les
artistes à zurich est le monde qui est
très passionné il risque d'avoir le rêve
dans vive mais quand on vit ça c'est à
la fois de mégots bénédiction puis une
joie de tous gagnent quasiment
l'autoroute mais en même temps déjà
trouvé les ressources pour payer
détruire ses stocks un sentiment
d'urgence à produire quelque chose qui
va marcher avec l'autisme à poser trop
de questions
quelque chose de les ranger tout ceci
comme même la chose qu'il aime le plus
au monde
à force de faire à tous les jours le
feeling que steve jobs même site la job
là plutôt pour moi ces germes a tant
fait cesser j'essaye des fois puis je
pense que tout le monde sait qui est qui
qui qui qui qui est là
du monde qui vit de son honneur pourrait
pourrir la dépendance le ticket genre
des fois je me rappelle je fais un match
devrait tellement comme focus et plus
sur mon sentiment de méchantes de me
sentir comme bien d'autres moments c'est
sorti comme un peu nostalgique de 15 tu
avais pas à acom répondre aux impératifs
aux attentes ou à quoi que ce soit
puisque juste seul chez vous dans ta
chambre
personne ne savait c'est maintenant
comme ceux qui te pousser à faire
l'album solo de terrain que je
retrouvais la liberté de faire ce que je
veux le web puis aussi le côté nettement
même vraiment
thérapeute cycle de genre comme avoir
besoin d'adressés c'est comme de ceux de
prendre certaines émotions puis les
transformer en autre chose pour comme
juste et c'est exact ce vieux principe
rôti puis c'est pas que j'aurais pas pu
le faire dans des projets comme de
groupes comme à la clarinette savez quoi
mais c'est surtout des trucs plus +
diptyque remettons la mort d'un ami ou
comme une grosse peine d'amour aux gens
d'être ici c'est quand même pas tout le
monde vit des étapes comme ça au même
moment
c'est déjà ça peut des fois empruntis
com c'est exact c'est du genre comme je
voulais pas être posée dans un wagon et
26,6 aujourd'hui j'écris puisque la
musique je pense pas de cas de bain même
parler d'autres choses que ce soit en ce
moment c'est vrai
puis vu que ça jamais été un problème au
sein dallas clark est quelqu'un fasse
quoi que ce soit en solo en même temps
et tout le reste est la question se
posait même pas si j'étais plus jeune je
n'avais pas choisi ici c'est juste que
ce que j'ai commencé à faire du rap très
jeunes jusqu'à la fin j'en ai toujours
pas mal fait seule la classe commencer
certainement été comme une découverte
pour moi de travailler en gagne avec
tous les groupes du coin qui a plus
d'expérience donc strictement ces gars
là le premier que j'ai appris ces canaux
qui lui allait au cégep avec mon frère
enfin ils se sont rencontrés aux cégeps
et des amis puis qu'elle m'a happé déjà
cette époque là puis mon frère je vous
l'avais dit le lion comme bandai à
propos de sujets comme ça puis l'école
sont déjà fans de ken russell usa comme
des tisserands kong pitt si j avais
montré métriques puis thin ice man parce
que comme il y avait vraiment une
ouverture
puis c'est vrai de l'upci les odeurs
âcres la ligue ont toujours une
ouverture d'esprit à ce jour je trouve
remarquable à mon égard pasty comme la
job ces cas là car c'est un super groupe
sauf moi c'est carrément seul tu sais
quand même ce qu'ils vendent leurs que
jean tout petits se moquer c'est comme
ayman puis claude d'accrophone avec
keanu avec mais watson avec tim hdd
mauvais appui de tampico personnes 6 6 4
c'est juste la passe clairement les
autres doute et on donnera pas droit
c'est ça d'autres comme si comme si
j'étais passé de le corps de basket de
ton parc jean locales à la nba
ces gens là d'autres outils comme étant
en train d'anticiper ce témoin non
périmés premier show avis ces gens c'est
avec ces gars là devant des portes gros
petit vent des vrais public gip à l'uag
accord de prêt peuvent être les formes
rondes en mai j'ai fait la peur le peu
anonyme c'est à dire comme quasiment
genre même pas mince et j'enregistre mes
mails aux fins obsessivement puis qu'il
soit beaucoup plus tous les jours le
mais comme fruste à la mecque médium
seule la chaîne abc comme juste article
du genre je fais du rap compulsivement
mais comme pour grand monde entendu quoi
que ce soit réparé réalise des trucs
vraiment non même si ses 106 tout ça
c'est à cette époque si je te disais que
ce serait un déjà je veux pas sans épée
dames et stands et conseil que je peux
donner aux plus jeunes parce que les
jeunes sont tellement du dos puis super
gignac s'est mêlé une façon de comme
surtout éduquer sur youtube st-a bref
tout le kit puis je les filles
complètement de vouloir sortir des
chutes jeunes parce que je remarque que
quand on premier truc dont il sortit
gêne les quais de sitôt le maine
il ya quelque chose aussi de très payant
a comme travailler son challenge au 04
en plus le seul coûte parce que ces
interminables mais à long terme le type
à être vraiment content si le premier
shift qui sortis publiquement par n'est
encore comme ça tu t'es tu es au stade
du pakistan
jamais été dans home et ce jusqu'aux
scènes pour ceux déjà le premier shit
public qui saute moins 80 enfants
puisqu'au sein ainsi comme j'ai fait du
port est de plus mais je consens exact
semaine je dois admettre pour moi je
trouve ça louche énorme le sujet rien à
rien en juin ont tous c'est qu'en penses
tu qu'il y avait des trucs et des
sorties qui ont été sources aux avances
au sarapp nous y écoute 26 pour ce
retard ne sera jamais un effet mais je
pense que j'aurais pas eu le feeling
comme de liberté totale tu ouais parce
que moi ce que ça fait comme comme comme
si de gamme offre cette opportunité
combat c'est que ces gens puis moi
j'allais vu un peu comme ok ils me font
confiance bas comme tchao l'escaut si je
veux pas non plus passer le balai dans
le coin en attendant ces gens comme ces
épices pour ce que les gens jettent et
comme kim heger comme je peux et rend
vraiment un élément de surprise un peu
puis je pense que toute cette espèce
vaisseau c'est ce qui m'a plu mots qui
m'a amené ou se moquer mais fauqué
domaine
je vais en faire un personnage comme un
ticket le pied un peu comme même rire du
rap ce faisant ce que j'aime soldats
mais aussi parce que c'est une façon on
peut nourrir des fois comme tipi je me
sentais comme ok mais personne attend à
ce que comme attac roxio de moi que je
sois je t'avais le carthage étaient
calmes au québec en double je bois pas
je vais pas faire un choix
c'est quand même un truc comme pas
failli parce que sinon en plus je sais
les douze personnes
oui mais non seulement les gosses en
fait une place dans sa bentley qui
n'était pas connu dans le fond quelle
était la recrue
puis j'ai l'impression que ta couleur a
vraiment un gros impact à la classe en
casquette apporte t au niveau des idées
je sais pas si je suis petit je sais pas
si le bas-canada ça ça vient uniquement
de toi outils robert nelson psaumes et
j'ai l'impression que il
on s'entend naissance dans l'accord a
beaucoup débattu ben je pense que ce
qu'est ce que
qui comme il ya certains éléments ou
l'essence d'un membre se présente comme
plus plus comme plus clairement qu'un
autre c'est moi je prends le mans lui
que le moins d'impact sur le côté
purement musical acquis ensemble parce
que je suis le moins musiciens de la
gang se joue aucun instrument de musique
pitivi bits mais qui est un peu quand
j'étais jeune je suis pour comprendre
les bars il comparaît donc des fois les
gens me demandent des chanteurs dans
weeds et puis je dis non ce n'est pas
tant que ça chanter moi je fonce souvent
quand j'étais jeune roi des rois
les doutes sont toutes les 57 des
missions s'effectuent en tant qu'homme
c'est moi chez le dos de qui ça rend pas
compte
capcom cas y apprend dans le mixeur 1,46
et moi c'est ce qu'on aurait dit la fin
de mai tandis que j'ai pas mal plus je
prends un habillage plus de ces de
théâtre d'impro oueds et des
littératures et j'étais moi j'ai plus
amené justement le côté qui des fois
qu'ils sont aux yeux de ces deux
éléments soudain jallet bas-canada
justement la mythologie autour de
l'apparence
c'était génial parce que les gosses au
sien des trucs incroyables qu'ils ont
fait ce qu'ils m'ont ils m'ont comme il
était de down avec ce que je sais faire
l'espèce de mythe on a un parent à
claude aussi l'espèce de mètres autour
de la classe vraiment la limite la
mythologie puis si nous avons les plus
importantes c'est pour que ça reste dans
tout ça marque les gens je pense que
c'est une loi qui crée vraiment le
sentiment d'appartenance au sein des
fanci et des com qui décode qu'un cadet
il ya un jargon qu'inquiets des images
qui rassemble y jeter votre club
kenavo chaud il s'appelle toutes les
mains oui c'est ce type i c'est la même
chose qu'ont déjà fou qu'est devenue
cité les mots que tu inventes sacré ce
sentiment d'appartenance l'est de sacrer
une sous-culture enfants c'est très
puissante cccc plus à nous génial c'est
que j'en sais moi des fois des gens me
demandent à everest eu comme
des pêcheurs de la fed mettant j'entre
je m'attends le lancement du genre
médecine squames en titre qui pourrait
vraiment faire un gentil toi moi et me
disent que tu as quel monde du sport
achète du match tant mieux mais la
feuille du boss pas nous on n'a pas de
paraître là dessus on n'a pas même
d'avoir le tiche d un non-sens de
s'approprier ce symbole là à nous déjà
été avertis comme tchao c'est moi un
moment mon rêve dans vie puis je le
verrai époque mon accomplissement je le
verrai comme nice comme gérant dû
justement encore moins à moi le mega man
je me balade dans rue petite la crèche
et des routes du québec ce bal comme
majeur un jour je m'abonne enrichir
l'offre
moi je sais pas si kim peek a boo dubois
son balcon du duce les fait lui même est
sorti tu sais comme ses trônes haïti
c'est tellement contre tout ce qui nous
est présenté maintenant ce que tu aimes
dire là de dire mon but ce serait qu'il
y ait plus de monde qui s'approprient
cette affaire là on a inventé mais ces
malades est comparé ceux qui diraient
faites-vous notre mec qui dirait non
respect
voici le pnj je vais pas te le donner
d'autres google images et qui m'épaule
l'ifp j'ai fait jusqu'à travail à laval
c'est exactement cela le design inverse
le tour le drapeau quand le lacrosse
jérôme alcool mais on a fait ça aussi
avec la musique au tout début titres
comme juste à la donne en égratignant
pitt et moi je pense que c'est tout le
monde tellement de johri laika ek te
manger aux expérimentations dans sa
vraie vie comme des fois tu donnes de
quoi mène avec aucune intention même
c'est comme si lui n'y va au complet le
chichon depuis j'attends renvoi six fois
plus n'était même pas soutenu bull est
moindre et justes dans l'impression que
cette personne c'est spécifiquement
pastel et peau en vidant leur tour 15
c'est comme un peu c'était il ya un peu
de ça dans des enfants d'un même métier
l'amendé afin de motiver par des
stratégies marketing et des parents même
des études qui démontrent que jean des
fois comme c'est quand même et moi c'est
pour ce qui m'intéresse c'est l'idée de
gens qui comme sa passion aux gens
qu'ils reçoivent exacte et puis comme
moi si je capable d'en en matant cité
fait beau ce t shirt et puis cadre d'un
régime est-allemand là heureusement il
est des histoires d'horreur l'apparent
par les enfants de ne pas offrir ça
existe puisque n'importe qui et des
façons de protéger son métier des
enfants je pense que la manne issue pu
te suis plus absurde a estimé l'homme a
participé à toi c'est plus comme c'est
un ou deux ans de ginette reno partie
est ce que c'est bon ouais la version de
les battre grosbill
l'essentiel c'est de toute beauté totti
disait quelque chose qui me c'est moi
c'est quelque chose qu'on me dit moi
j'ai nagé longtemps je mangeais 20 ans
ma vie la dation clergé au puy à mener
avant que nick mairie etc outre son
important parce que xala numérique lui
était plus vieux que moi y avait s'il y
avait six ans plus que moi je pense pim
on m avait dit mme n prends ton temps
qui m'a regardé et m'a dit tu comprends
pas ce que je te dis on prend ton temps
parce que quand tu vas être rangés afin
de de ceux qui vont regretter pas avoir
pris ton temps puis moi quand j'ai
reçues sur je m'étais dit maintenant que
ça se passe puis comme de fait six ans
après quand je finissais ma cage must
eat tabarnak j'aurais peut-être dû
prendre plus mon temps puis quand on
faisait les jeunes que c'est comme ces
daubes ce qu'ils font maintenant sûr que
ces daubes ce qu'ils font maintenant
peut-être prends ton temps qu'elle
serait fait de différent quand on a vu
plus prends ton temps gérer j'aurais
arrêté l'école en une année
cependant j'ai pour manger un parce que
tu as le droit syndical lui verser dans
le monde j'aurais arrêté l'école une
année pour commencer mais cinq ans plus
tard ok pour finir plus vieux pour avoir
une année de plus de carrière peut-être
même deux ans
maintenant que tu me demandes sont
maintenant peut-être que je prendrai
deux ans de plus j'aurais pris deux ans
de plus de ma carrière
j'aurais arrêté l'école pendant deux ans
puis j'aurais pris deux ans de plus de 4
milliards est encore à fixer fait que si
j'avais été vraiment de dire prends ton
temps j'aurais vraiment pris plus moment
mais tu vois tous ces genres de conseils
que je pense qu'ils super bon score
personnel pour certaines personnes et
pour d'autres potence qui va soit ça
c'est ce qui va faire qui prendront pas
leur temps c'est comme ça c'est que des
fois aussi des fouilles année qui
prennent trop leur temps puis vous avez
besoin d'y aller je pense que c'est plus
mon corps même pendant tellement
longtemps c'est comme si je passe pour
un gain de fond car je pratique franco
reprise pas compris le tout sortira
aussi le mets ton travail tu puisses il
a travaillé
miller et steve guerdat cospar à amman
et l'été sur le bilan à amman et c'est
aussi en faisant les choses que tu
t'améliores à faire ces choses-là trifi
qui se sent jamais prefect tu fais pas
parce que tu te dis je le fais quand
j'aurai vraiment après les soucis des
farc étudié meilleurs pilotes de leurs
frappes de leur force de leur foi
puis si sofac bref quelqu'un pour des
gens trop pressé prend l'accent peut
retravailler temps fort api qui
entraverait bas prévoient s'ils étaient
des gens qui voudraient se faire dire
active le genre arrêt de thomas rompuy
fait l'être la phase d'investissement de
6 pi c'est ce même mois après chaque
achat votre feeling album j'ai toujours
eu l'impression que c'était comme le
match et quelques cons afin d'acheter
comme j'ai toujours l'impression aux
puits j'ai toujours l'impression qu'à ce
moment à l'autre
peut-être tel détaillerait peut être un
peu mieux très hermétique grosso modo
note 6 10 août c'est ce qu'on présente
et où on est on venu
puis ç'a toujours été la même chose un
an après je crois même album je reçois
bourideys bourij aurait complètement ces
gens je trouve pas ça pourrit loin de
genres très à l'aise de les frères chaud
et froid comme je trouve d'autres
charges et je prends ma job comme sur
espacejeux com d'eau dans nos arénas
j'ai fait assez de progrès pour comme
que certains heures que je voyais pas
vendre logent les boîtiers est-ce que ça
me laisse comme impression c'est que
c'est la honte d'aimer perfection c'est
toujours relatif à une phase mais
parfait où est ce que je t'ai rend leur
exacte des besoins en fait un des
meilleurs trucs que tu peux t'offrir
éventuellement quand tu quand tu décides
que ces moments de justement aller au
grand jeu puis sortir des trucs c'est
justement de comme pas trop attendre
genre de tout avoir fait parfait parce
que même si tu es rendu ça m'est tombé
dessus de travailler six fois plus tu
passé pro terrain du stade fame and
cheats le suspect campagne perfectible
et aucun défaut rien dans le monde
entier je parie n'importe quelle équipe
ces jeunes amateurs comme je pars faire
mieux ce serait tellement beau à la fois
que j'écoute un album 4 1 après puis
commencer tellement meilleur que ce que
j'ai fait la semaine passée c'est des
fois c'est même plus payant la chose que
tu as fait spontanément qui bourrine
imperfections mais qui une spontanéité
que du caractère que le truc est à
travailler et stipule qu' il faut qu'ils
vivent dans de mauvaises trouve à cause
de la procédure
moi je prêche à l'énorme fans de l'impro
en tant que tel team déjà riche
je trouve que c'est comme c'est les gens
très drôle qu'ils font et du stand up et
de l'impro souvent j'ai trop juste plus
grave c'est là ça ne me touche pas à mon
mec comme c'est hot affolé cependant les
pros de full expérience tant d'autres
mais genre 4 rien préparé je te trouve
que m +3 oui c'est ce que je suis
vraiment si je veux pas je pas une
critique attendre quand tu m'avais pas
dit très bon complément toutefois avoir
un show du mot piqué la partie
cloudworks et lorsqu'elle l'art s'y
frotter parce que je tape antilles et il
ya de quoi mène de magique dans
programme à vivre un moment unique
ce moment le il jamais même techno fois
puis jose est impressionnant à voir
quelqu'un de sortir de quoi de drôle on
ne
capa et qu'ils avancent que factice à
emule la vraie vie tu parce que of
course the pledge entre le monde qui se
spécialise dans faire rire les gens
c'est une business
mais là la vraie vie c'est que j'allume
aux envies tout ceux comme tous les
jours tout le temps avec nos amis nos
familles et ces 10e puis c'est tout le
temps spanta dirais tu si personne n'est
prêt par carl cox puis fait 4 6 voix de
l'impro ça te rappelles-tu concernant ça
te rappelle la vraie vie se rappelle
lumeau les vrais moments drôles de
l'erreur qui sort jamais de la vie
ceux qui sont pas encadrées
nécessairement avec le temps chaud
encadré qui donne l'impression que pas
encore rien fait comme sauf ça bien des
fois comme ça vient chercher la fibre
fondamental dit le fou rire le plus fou
que tu n'as d'avis quasiment sauf que
c'est pas un professionnel du rire
quitte à les dénoncer des faits sont
encore de la poudre
j'en fais plus comme comme en tant que
joueur mais c'est vrai que la peau du
club
j'en aime les shows effectif encore à
fond dans l'impro dans le dans le milieu
de l'impro si on veut mais c'est ça j'ai
joué mon rôle j'ai joué deux à quatre
plus jeunes ou au cégep
puis après seule la musique participe au
fait que j'avais moins le temps mais
j'étais tellement j'aimais tellement le
milieu d'un projet dans le médium qui
est justement j'ai eu envie de tenter
d'asseoir le cégep c'est souvent c'est
souvent l'incubateur c'est comme le
cégep le sait vraiment lamy le mythique
leur garneau je m'appelle y avait la
ligue d'impro le monde lady jaye puis
après ça tout seul on le transfère
universités cheikh et moi tout les
vendredis soir j'allais voir dans lui la
lui
ah oui merci à 20h les tout laisse
penser que les raisons exactes plein
d'amis qui encore aujourd'hui je pense
que ces gens là font encore l'impro
d'essai avant à droite ses clients c'est
souvent un truc que le monde qui
embarque puis enfants pour ça comme
changement vitrine saatchi dire ça mais
c'est vraiment si comme ça et puis des
fois il ya des côtes up un peu un plus
petit prix décoté un peu moins nice des
fois au fait qu'ils prennent accepter
surtout il n'est pas que les cas les
gens sont un peu plus jeune que sa
crinière chi sociale forte s'est piqué
comme si c'était pas voir les produits
pour kool 6 comme plate les gens c'est
drôle parce que parce que dans l'opinion
générale ceux qui font un procès mais
j'en rêve mais ça change ça change mais
aussi parce que comme les jeunes en ce
moment se rendre compte que dans la
relève des humoristes ferment des outils
je suis même persuadé relève parce que
j'ai en moi comme des manques méfier du
monde qui sont encore dit de la relève
mais j'en oublie ce sont trop de la
relève le monde en termes de marges en
crabos il cessa l'exacte sans son accord
ou son complément 28 mai juste pas son
jeune on dit là c'est julien lacroix et
l'absurde à dire que julie la couette
animaux rizla khaled méchaal mais la
nouvelle génération d'humoristes annotel
l'humain qui en fait l'argent
je pense à 1008 même que je pense à
julien qui pensent à virgile forte que
tu penses à harnes australie
france lampre qui tient avec franck pâti
comme si tous les créneaux de l'impro
c'est juste auto parts du club derrière
tu y fais que c'est comme si je pense
que ça va devenir de plus en plus
évident dans la tête des jeunes mais
consciemment qui comme si tu rêves au
théâtre à la télé le cinéma
toute l'équipe de l'humour le stand up
la première place tu peux pas aller
faire des siennes dans les bars quant
aux 12
ça s'est passé pour rejoindre l'équipe
d'impro attendent école secondaire
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que c'est une des
activités qui doit stimuler le plus
toutes les ententes ont servi en même
temps moi j'ai dit après avoir fait des
études en musique jazz fidh le phare se
tait dans la vie jeudi il y avait les
études mettant sa cravate disgrâce il
faut improviser de garde son cerveau
puis voit justement que c'est une des
activités le plus d'amants d'anthony
votre cerveau absolument tout et il
stimule et puis je les présente un
brossardois est exactement le silence
parce que ça travaille tellement tu
t'investis d'esprit tonton sentons sens
comique mais aussi ton ton jeu
dramatique parfois aussi c'est tellement
justement large présence quelque chose
que tu commences piqué disputant pas su
non plus comme l'épopée canepa casnos à
faire une confession
je me vois pas pu faire ce petit jeu
c'est que s'il ya plus haut il va avoir
un bébé vraiment c'est de la création de
carrément la création site epeat eu
c'est le fun de sentir que quand il
écoute qui se passait à mon équipe de
l'observer à l'extérieur c'est vraiment
senti si n'auront-ils l'humain est fait
pour avoir satisfaction lot c'est déjà
observée comme on est chanceux parce que
mène t on à l'époque où vous avez deux
parties un podcast on apprend beaucoup
de gens qui vous écoutent ces maladies
comme puis même même principe mais tant
que la avec la musique est plein de
jeunes autistes sauter c'est ce que je
pense qu'ils
ce qui est remarquable si on veut en 10
mai dans toute la dombes du moment
civilisationnel profit les problèmes qui
nous affligent peut-être aussi les
affaires rallier autant la technologie
sociaux de l'équipe mais socialisme un
peu comme ces seuls gens puissent se
dire oui c'est ce qui tire juste avoir
toutes les personnes qui étaient nommés
pearl jam eddie puis tout un ex mars
toutes les grandes joies d'un procès des
gens c'est ce type voient sont vifs
d'esprit sont drôles triés puis le musée
c'est la poule ou l'oeuf le ts qu'est ce
qu'il t'est bon impôt parce qu'ils sont
eux mêmes d'abord jouent les uns pour
les informer probablement appelé un peu
des deux mais j'ai vraiment l'impression
qu'ils aient quelque chose le kit for
une espèce de raie manta le chercher ce
nul part ailleurs complètement puis par
la suite comme plusieurs des promus par
les professionnels d'autant que comme un
diamant tant qu'acteur dans des moments
qui sont pas de l'impro systématiquement
la brousse comme la leur outil magique
lé j'en passe qui comme mettons un autre
comédien que jamais c'est un pro mais
qui est un excellent comédien
si jamais je sais pas si quelqu'un peut
dire exactement bonne réplique qui me
laisse à ceux qui bloquent ou choquer
comme évidemment y ait moins huilé a
comme versus changement impromptu s'com
services et nos réflexions
potentiellement même qui va trouver une
façon de les parcours mythique mieux que
le scénario va mieux c'est j'imagine
qu'il ya des real qui doivent des fois
je le dis quand je ne cache pas un cache
pas un comédien qui font avancer
l'histoire avec l'insee il était cassé
le scénario avait été écrit avec lui en
tête puis il avait essayé plusieurs
acteurs avec lui sauf que sa technique
d'acting lui c'est juste de l'impro de
fake lui il y arrivait ses plateaux
pelés improvisait pied il y avait aucun
égard à dire donner le truc annulera
l'effet est le même qui connaît tous
quelqu'un qui serait capable de coups et
lui avait dit oh nous sommes passés à
midi lui un chèque on joue bien sans un
faux document aux landais
les a finalement ils y ont commencé à
improviser sur le site donné le film ça
donne c'est quand même mais c'est sûr
que oui il ya quelque chose que tu viens
défleuries que moi c'est une réflexion
que j'ai juste dans les derniers jours
puis je me sens à quelqu'un qui qui qui
va au moins faire avancer mon idée sur
ceux de parler des réseaux sociaux de
parler de certains problèmes qu'ont
convient qu'on est forts de mon ensemble
dernièrement hub en fait il y aurait eu
l'événement juste pour ados wac est un
genre d'événement ou ce qu'ils avaient
des influenceurs qui est calé le puits
ce matin un vol articles de marque a su
qu'elle s'est dit dans la presse qui
sort des civils
cassivi moi qui étais qui était vraiment
réducteur a grossièrement la culture du
vide qui vous qui relié au tour de sa
vie est un énorme amalgame avec toutes
les toutes les créateurs de contenu web
en mettant tout le monde dans le même
panier puis puissamment lumière quelque
chose qui est que je me questionnais
déjà par rapport à la place qu'on offre
tout le monde qui créent du contenu sur
le web c'est nous on est des créateurs
de contenu étant l'une avec le sans fil
avec le podcast on avait invité
justement aller injuste pour ados fake
très affecté je trouve qu'il ya vraiment
je trouve qu'il ya un danger avec
l'accessibilité à tout le monde de créer
du contenu
puis le jeu le dit complètement
humblement je trouve que nous on crée du
contenu qui qui qui pousse la réflexion
mais je trouve que quand même une
culture du vide dans ce milieu si je
trouve que c'est dangereux pour être
avec toi je t'ai on connaît on a des
amis qui donne sur les réseaux ou même
j'ai vu jean les images de mal à l'aise
pour vrai je ne sais pas qui suivra et
mara jade dans mais l'espèce d'adèle 10
dollars
opération de relations avoir des justes
le principe de 10 de loterie quelqu'un
juste ça me dépasse un peu je trouve ça
un peu oui
piliers quelque chose pour le moment là
est un genre espèces 2
telle personne qui fait passer aux neuf
c1 ratifie moi je partage ton à cugnaux
plus j'ai faites aux personnes
georges les fêtes mais j'ai de la
difficulté à je pense qu'il ya un danger
société à cultiver le vide comme ceux a
que les jeunes surtout l'est et surtout
des adolescentes de la relation aussi
mais que les jeunes et en estime
tellement autres des gens qui
grossièrement font plus ce qu'on fait
ici puis moi je n'aurais pas ça qu'un
jeune mis dans l'autre vous je veux dire
j'ai beaucoup de points négatifs que je
cache ma c'est beaucoup de pression mais
moi j'aime à penser comme c'est comme ça
c'est la pression le tir avorté de ce
comité était automatiquement aussi oui
par rapport à moi j'aime pas beaucoup
lalalala clamant je suis pas cliquer
beaucoup de si je peux très à l'aise
avec la notion de sphère en effet y de
la route sèche qui s'adonnent des
relations beaucoup verticale
ces gens là ton com - c'est un disque
animatrix que je devrais que le taq
comme approche puis vivien un genre
comme je sens tout gentillesse comme
donner des preuves ce que je suis je me
sens tout le temps peu mal à l'aise mais
je suis jamais rendu dans la zone où je
les accepte complètement dans le pur
plaisir de ça fait comme il ya toujours
un peu une petite gêne si vous y relatif
mais mais comme maintenant ce que
j'essaie de me dire c'est que assez
rapidement j'ai c'est de demander une
question à la personne ce qui était
assez déséquilibré parce qu'elle connaît
tant de choses sur moi
moi je connais même pas son nom
s'effectue hors jeu j'ai envie de cette
île comme et merci beaucoup merci où le
suis pas c'est comment tu t'appelles
maintenant je suis juste ce geste là je
trouve automatiquement simplement un
vertical simplement puis c'est seul
danger paraît par contre avec avec thé
avec avec l'interpellé sociaux c'est que
comme à la fois l'impression que la
personne ait foule proches puis
accessibles effect comme un peu
l'illusion de l'horizontalité mais on
s'entend c'est beau ça quelques cas
spécial et a quand même des morières qui
séparait les adolescents des gratteurs
de on est au milieu
je trouve quelque chose d'extrêmement
mars un danseur mais je suis pas garde
de mettre le doigt dessus petit jeu vous
emmèneront un tel est le pitch est que
ma blonde a un impact extrêmement
positif sur sur certains assurent sur
les adolescents que la sûreté mais j'ai
l'impression que cette relation la
déconne j'ai l'impression qu'on cultive
quelque chose qui va être nocif
éventuellement j'ai eu ma pensée pas
abouti je veux juste la bande c sur une
nouvelle map ans et ma pensée par
rapport à ces pas abouti mais j'ai
l'impression qu'en tant que société on
cultive quelque chose d'un peu nocifs
quand on commençait à mettre sur un
piédestal
puis moi je suis le premier à utiliser
instagram pour faire l'argent était là
mettre sur un piédestal du monde utilise
des plateformes pour pousser des trucs à
des adolescents bah oui c'est clair que
c'est un ccc s'étoffe de ce match je
trouve dans la peau de coop dans deux
jeunes comment ça fonctionne socialement
soit puis aussi dans le cerveau d'un
jeune quel espace réellement que prince
ta g
on n'a pas connu une laquelle point on
peut même on a l'impression qu'ils
l'occupent teint de place mais peut-être
ça n'occupe encore plus ou peut-être
même pas mal moins que le gel c'est
quand même si c'est pas un madoff mais
un truc par contre que je pense c'est
que tous les gens qui se ramasse dans
une position d'avant un gros ricciotti
ça veut pas dire qu'ils étaient obligés
du jour la demande est traitée comme par
défaut responsables ces gens je pense
processus et comme tous les êtres
humains et même même les mêmes même déjà
même les les jeunes
les mineurs tout le monde a une part de
libre arbitre la france le tipi comme
c'est rohff qui combine glandois en
train d'oublier affaires de quality déjà
en même temps c'est comme mais ceux qui
sont persuadés
puis c'est une question personnelle à
laquelle je la seule personne qui peut
répondre c'est soi-même mais si tu es
persuadé que tu dessus infuse du love la
positivité qui était en train de prendre
de quoi qui est en toi puisque tu cher
aux autres man piketty comme se fait pas
toujours parfaitement mais il y en aura
dans ce processus si tu files
authentiquement comme ça notre copie
rendue le parfaite mais genre en effet
cité carrément 100% consciente des
rendus où tu trouves pas manqué de plus
en plus ce qui fait que tu es un peu
dans ces la rentabilisation des likes
comme un peu t plus en train de pousser
quelque chose c'est comme via le même
principe amusé c'est à dire que si tu es
même plus d'armes avec la musique que tu
étais je suis en train de la faire parce
qu'ils arrêtent les bijoux comme ça mais
c'est là où tu es le premier qui devrait
supporter ton propre bien même pas posé
la question suis-je à la bonne place au
bon endroit où faire là en train de
faire la bonne affaire
puis c'est parce que je pense que je
pense que c'est off c'est tellement dû
qu'au parc j'ai ainsi comme il ya
probablement qui est kader qui fait ce
genre de chose doit piquer ses flancs
super néfastes et déjà quelqu'un qui
fait sens civique chose d'accessible à
lui à sa façon et tous les documents
pour respectifs 6,6 à 5,6 depuis
antilles mais c'est sur la foi parce que
par que de dire tout le monde qui
participent à ce soit le pense ou se
convainc que c'est positif
sauf que est-ce qu'on a une
responsabilité en tant que société de
cordiale de ces affaires le mettons
kérygme étant quelqu'un prendre quelque
chose qui est négatif mais c'est sûr que
c'est personnel pense que c'est positif
deux premiers se pense que ce qui met de
l'avant ce ça élève la conversation t
mais si ça les six à l'élève pas
réellement qui a le devoir de n'en
parler mais si si si c'est ce qui est à
che ck val certaine époque terme et ont
scellé
les canaux de diffusion sociétaires sont
très riches en avant qui était
quelconque type de contenu qui se
rendent à un ordre des jeunes puissent à
distance consommer ce qu on leur fait
faire plusieurs chèques te défiles
décideurs il ya un énorme fossé van
hamme et aussi des fois des facteurs là
dans le team puis comme le ces genres
complètement l'inversé 100 m c'est sûr
que c'est cameron et d'alpha ouest
absolument complètement le puits t des
fois c'est que je veux pas moi même
tomber dans le piège de la personne qui
est comme un peu plus vieille que le
sémaphore ce domaine - ben des affaires
qu'il ya des français qui font leur
ardeur que je trouve ce insipide et
complètement signifiant le dépiquage à
l'enrobage de ce groupe là dessus je le
trouve pour convaincre je suis pas sûr
que total a de la répartie en même temps
je connais pas la personne c'est à
fatima méthode ce qui me dérange suis
obligé de dire que j'en pense maintenant
il supporte la tête de faire une
distanciation entre les 2 mai mais quand
on parle de jeunes qui sont qui sont des
éponges ainsi dangereux qui est un
modèle pour eux devient devient la chose
à faire la façon de poser la vraie
question c'est tout dit d'accord avec ce
que tu veux dire qu'il y en aura des
risques et je me dis tabarnak que si
vite et puis il ya des jeunes qui
regardent ce qu'ils font ah ouais c'est
ça ça c'est problématique
bah oui je pense qu'il faut on est
tellement dirais pas que les gens sont
très sensibles puisque avec man qui a
une culture de cette fois attention aux
différentes sensibilités déjà of corse
meja moi je pense quand même qu'il faut
qu'ils tiff
s'il faut pas tomber dans le bitchage
gauche mais j'en sais si ce corps est qu
un commentaire construit comme moi je
pense personnellement que j'ai entendu
trop de gens se plaindre de la pression
que l'image créée dans société ppi qui
vont ensuite par la suite en pro comm
tu fais c'est tout le monde est une
contradiction bilan c'est tout le monde
fait ça mais il ya des degrés le tee
shirt c'est comme un peu c'était en
train si tu te considères comme le
mettant si je donne un exemple une autre
job je vise personne en même temps qui
était une fille une jeune fille
considère que grant agenais semaine à
donges adultes se trouve que beaucoup de
pression au niveau de l'image comme ceux
puisque tamasu frère c'est quand je suis
complètement normal mais pose tous des
questions sur mon post était perçu les
arrange sur photoshop important des
questions tu es tu en train de
contribuer ou pas à ce type de phénomène
ceux d'entre eux
je pars en train de dire que je
comprends pas certaines des offres tout
s'explique les gens métier de toi même
la possibilité d'arriver à ta propre
conclusion cm comme il faut se poser des
questions comme ce sens je pense que le
questionnement nécessaire j'ai
l'impression soit je te poser la
question sur les jusqu'en women crise et
l'échec c'est qu'est-ce qu'ils ou elles
aussi avec instagram spécifiquement
c'est qu'il y ait jamais eu autant comme
le réseau social de tout comme paul
choix de moi le moyen de manquer d'un
milieu public le mieux d arracher
terrain c'est pas vrai cette offre
à moins que ça soit le new shit bientôt
de pomme d'avoir toutes ces ultis la
game change tout le talent mais votre
choix
en effet comme tout le monde et comment
vas tu fais chier mais ça me fait chier
de devoir face à mes sources je le vois
bien quand je le fais ça c'est là que la
responsabilité personnelle et être très
forte ici tu peux tu peux toi même te
dire ce compris rtt ce que je préfère me
sentir particulièrement les ex que je
fais d'abord moins de deux succès
quantitatif âme et on est ce que je
préfère comme quand même aller vers le
succès quantitatif mais en essayant de
rester le plus fidèle à moi même jusqu'à
mantes sim est en jeu
je collectais des dizaines et des
dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
d'interactions web avec particulièrement
des à dole
il ya moi je sais que ça me plairait
beaucoup à accepter je suis récemment
créé beaucoup puis genre je me demande
des fois même si ça ne nécessite pas un
peu un degré de désensibilisation des
fois comme quand tu c'est comme quand tu
es conscient que tellement de gendt
arias peut-être qu'il mène pour ta
propre santé mentale t'as pas le choix
des valeurs on est au coeur parce que
c'est normal aussi
voilà peut-être choisi parce que
viscéral à la société bien connue au
lendemain à cause de chez paquet ce qui
est arrivé comme toute l'équipe de 15
ans québec tonfa l'eau puis j'arrive
même si sylvain octobre les gens jettent
à l'eau
alors je dis pas été là dedans ça reste
humble mais à faire sur les réseaux
sociaux on dit mais comparé à métro où
certains stades dont on parle mais si
j'avais des enfants soi même
je sais pour commencer j'ai mangé est-ce
que tu l'aimés tu instagram est ce que
parce que c'est ce que tu dises que si
on la disait qu'elle est compliquée dans
un jour faste qui était limite nos têtes
à limites morales mes limites morales
d'haïti qui je dépenserai pas cette
ligne là c'est mettons qu'il cherche pas
la somme est on moi personnellement
mettons posté une photo en pièce jointe
à g je parle je ne ferai jamais été ou à
le sport et j'ai fait ce crochet ça non
mais est ce que vous arrivez tout une
limite à ce qu'on se dit moi je
franchirais pas ceux pour les like où je
serai prêt si je ferais pas ça mais qui
l'autre côté il ya toujours quelqu'un
plus avoir de like que tu pas que c'est
le mot rodionova
l'expérience est une monnaie déjà passé
le seuil et plusieurs monnaies dans le
monde qui sont ce qu on a près des
monnaies digitales ou des captures mais
moi mon hypothèse personnellement à tous
à toutes les dynamiques et le
comportement d'une vraie monnaie c'est à
dire que ja ça vaut quelque chose selon
ce qu'on pense que ça vaut puisque l'on
ce qu'on est prêt à se dire que ça vous
à la base ça ne vaut rien combien le
tipi foot une époque où il valait
réellement delors puis de leur savoir ça
que j'ai un vrai matériaux mais
aujourd'hui l'argent ça vaut rien
aujourd'hui des likes savons rien mais
ça vaut tout en même temps on sait cela
n'a d'herbe toutes races que la valeur
qu'ils attribuent danton exactement puis
comme quelque chose c'est là où
admettant le moov'in sa gamme récemment
de peut-être enlever les la sauce et des
questions qui sont vraiment
intéressantes se jetant d'un point de
vue de ce site un gros mot quel impact
sociologie que ça va avoir sur les gens
si je pas intéressant s'est fixé on est
ici tough de faire l'histoire
n'ayant jamais même nc comme il ya
clairement des trucs qui se passe là
qu'ils ont un impact massif le sol et
nimani le rap pilé et pop se voit
reproché de prôner justement des valeurs
discutables maintenant surtout certains
darty cependant à parler plutôt d'un
podcast est ce que vous lancez une deux
une critique que vous avez reçue à la
clé mettons pas en bloc je ne m'attends
pas de façon récurrente c'est vrai mais
oui à des chevaux des défauts des gens
qui qui nous ont rappelés mannequins
comme beaucoup de jeunes qu'ils écoutent
comme ça ou que comme mais si je te
dirais que en général aux entraînements
c'est favorable non loin du compte si
vous n'avez pas c'est pas genre il
faudrait vraiment comme tout le monde
des doses qui qui qui qui qui qui
sauveront nano on a nos particularités
on n'est pas des bad guys mon époque on
n'est pas non plus fondamentalement des
chats ou du moins je vois je vois pour
ma part parce que tu sais pas bref wait
on essaie des questions tellement
tellement tellement intéressant puis je
sais par exemple que c'est sûr que cette
réflexion le pour l'ego du pad justement
qui ont des familles des enfants à s'est
passé différemment pour eux que pour sûr
si c'est normal parce que moi ça reste
théorique comme la notion que je serai
en maintenant les enfants puis comment
gérer ça mais aussi pour des gones
albane ses traits réels c'est-à-dire les
leurs propres enfants ils connaissent
l'automne voilà justement comme six
lames en automne comme je vais
l'attendre considération pareil quand
vous créez juste tes potes tu est
inconsciente mais ça plante pareil ouais
ouais et puis je pense que je pense
qu'on essaie tous de le vivre comme au
lieu de lever quelque chose qui serait
limitant ou une privation ou comme genre
fox comme off limits qui s'y posent
comme bastille comme des bonnes raisons
de faire ça mais en fait c'est ce qui
est en même temps tu peux prendre des
bonnes valeurs
ce serait décider autre pareil justement
tout ce qui compte la famille mais n'y
ait pas plus bonne valeur que ce messin
et si des cockpits et moi là bas c'est
comme moi il ya certaines choses que je
pense par rapport à l'art moderne c'est
que comme la vulgarité plein du site et
il fut un moment dans l'histoire de
laure qui en effet c'était comme ordre
de bach expliqué c'était comme chacun
sait que oui savez métier en 2019 a
nettement la vulgarité lundi des plats
viole le droit à logement contre
choristes rien là dedans qui meuf qui
vient me trouve je suis même pas un mode
world et courageux que tu grandis
d'aquitaine c'est dans un petit quartier
rohff ou est ce que c'est encore la
brutalité policière puisse se passer
encore les notes sont jetés dans les
rues
peut-être que ça va être ton message tu
es qui voit la violence ante et ex
mécréants spécialité mathématiques
oiseaux puis surtout comme ne vois pas
ça comme un saint de créativité des gens
de voir sinon invités pas vulgaire que
tu sais la moitié d'un trip 2 justement
faire autre chose
diverses des perfectionnements vraiment
mais comme si c'était savez convaincre
et essaie d'avoir une certaine attente
sur google et google
je sais qu'avec le tipi il ya toujours
eu des seuls à faire ce qu'il est urgent
d'époque en effet le peut-être plus
comme dans les années 40 des médecins et
des personnels qui sont treize comique
ait son mot à dire
c'était pas du tout non plus le dit mec
là mais on attribue quand même du strict
reda c'est lui qui leur offre plus
pêcheurs
je sais pas c'est normal c'est sûr qu'à
drapé de rapides saint-roch ça a plus de
crainte que de rap et de céleri mois
chez moi honnêtement même j'ai très hâte
de type est en train de se passer
mais si comme c'était un temps où nous
mettons les seules personnes qui
allaient faire du rock s'arrêter dès
déjà de classe ouvrière liquidités qui
pâtit comme qui ont peu de moyens été
bref entre tout une sociologie dur qui a
mené le rock est juste un peu plus
devenu une musique parmi tant d'autres
aujourd'hui doit pas descendre plein de
préjugés favorables ou défavorables qui
viennent avec lady of duty et elektrim à
nos petits comme gérard comme nibali qui
nous arrache mais leur a pas encore un
peu la notion déjà ok c'est quoi ta
raison pour faire tu n'as pas besoin de
vendre exemple la batterie comme
personne triturage ou la trompette
personne et comment me souviens de
quelques artistes rapport je la
trempette
c'est comme mais ce jeu vraiment hot que
dans l'europe que l'europe les yeux
parce que justement ça va permettre à
des gens qui ont tellement pas et
historiquement comme de pouvoir ça va
être vraiment curieux mais j'en ai déjà
de l'île des kills
blanquer durables puis je veux du
sauveur ou admettons comme une vieille
mémé chinoise c'est ce contrat du genre
qu'elle mène à leur réalité qu'on prend
pour sa part nous parlent de nos petits
j'améliore juste il que cette poule b
gens aujourd'hui c'est à maîtriser
encore une corrélation de gens les gens
qui sont pas dix minutes typiquement qui
créent des ravages et notre beau
football c'est ce que relâche est encore
très réelle mais même ça va être
tellement intéressant je pense et puis
moi je suis juge conscient qu'il peut y
avoir des risques par rapport à des
dérapages d'appropriation culturel que
qu'elle même si je suis soutenue comme
j'ai hâte que ça soit fait dans le bon
goût puis que ce soit comme rendu comme
que ça soit bien celle qui a mené porter
qui fasse appliquer aucune pas besoin
d'avoir de raison que ça reste de ta vie
des albums quelqu'un de très intéressant
merci beaucoup mais claude arrêter
l'exode
j'ai vraiment l'impression que c'est
qu'on va éviter le manda bay sur des
albums numéro un dans son pays croyant
mais sinon ben j'imagine qu'ils prennent
tout leur travail des pharmacopées on
croit que ça du malade
on est en famille babou cissé sa merci